programming throwdown episode 57 optimization take it away jason hey everyone wanted to start with a public service announcement. And I've seen this so many times. It just absolutely drives me up the wall. And it's one of these things I feel like I don't know if I'm getting like becoming like a crotchety old man or whatever. But, you know, I saw this. So I'm going to kind of exaggerate. But basically someone said, oh, there's a 1% chance of doing
Programming Throwdown 第 57 期：优化。开始吧，Jason。嘿，大家好，我想先做一个公益广告。这种情况我见得太多了，简直让我抓狂。这属于那种让我觉得——我不知道自己是不是变得像个脾气暴躁的老头子了，还是怎么回事。但是，你知道，我看到了这个，所以我要稍微夸张一点。基本上有人说：“哦，做这件事有 1% 的几率成功，所以我得做一百次才能成功。”你经常会看到这种情况，比如“哦，有 10% 的几率，所以这意味着你得做 10 次”。你经常看到这种说法，这简直让我抓狂。事情不是那样运作的。如果你做某事有 1% 的几率，并不意味着如果你尝试一百次，你就一定有 100% 的几率成功。这实际上比那复杂得多。我不会去讲公式之类的东西，其实我可以讲，这很简单。就是说，如果你做某事有 1% 的几率成功，那就意味着你有 99% 的几率失败。
this event. So I have to do it a hundred times to get it. And you see this a lot, like, oh, there's a 10% chance. So that means, you know, you have to do this 10 times or, you know, you see this a lot and it just absolutely drives me up the wall. It doesn't work that way. Like if you have, if you have a 1% chance of doing something, it doesn't mean that way. Like if you have, if you have a 1% chance of doing something, it doesn't mean that you have a hundred percent chance. If you try a hundred times, it means that it's actually more complicated than that. And I'm not going to like go into the formula or anything like that. It's actually, I can go into, it's pretty simple. It's just, if you have a 1% chance of doing something, then that means you have a 99% chance of failing.
（接上文）如果你做某事有 1% 的几率成功，那就意味着你有 99% 的几率失败。
So the chance that you succeed even once is 1 minus the chance that you fail every time, right? So if you have 1% chance of success, you have a 99% chance of failure. So if you do 0.99 to the 100th power, and I will put this into Wolfram Alpha. But if you have.99 to the 100th power, it is not 100%. Let's see what it says. This is really exciting radio right here.
所以，至少成功一次的几率是 1 减去每次都失败的几率，对吧？所以如果你有 1% 的成功率，你就有 99% 的失败率。所以如果你计算 0.99 的 100 次方，我会把它输入到 Wolfram Alpha 里。但如果你计算 0.99 的 100 次方，它不是 100%。让我们看看结果是什么。这真是激动人心的广播节目啊。
I like that you called it radio. 36. So if you have a 1 percent chance and you do have a hundred attempts then one minus 0.36 so 0.64 so you have about a two and three chance of succeeding at least one time out of a hundred and just you know i've been looking a lot at like you know polls and you know like it's politics season and so everyone tries to be a statistician and that's cool i think this is one of the few times of the quattro year it's one of the few times where people really care about statistics which is cool but don't make this
我喜欢你把它称为广播。结果是 36%。所以如果你有 1% 的几率，并且你尝试了一百次，那么 1 减去 0.36 等于 0.64，所以你在一百次尝试中至少成功一次的几率大约是三分之二。你知道，我最近看了很多民意调查，现在是政治季，所以每个人都试图成为统计学家，这很酷。我觉得这是四年里为数不多的几次人们真正关心统计学的时候，这很酷，但别犯这个错误，这会让统计学家抓狂的。
mistake it drives statisticians crazy that's a good point and it should also be pointed out that if you think about the formula as you were saying saying it, as you get closer, the, you start slowing down, right? So the, you're taking off a percentage each time, but the amount you increase gets small. I'm saying this really poorly that basically, so you did it a hundred times and you got to two thirds chance, but if you do it a hundred more, you're not going not going to again you're not going to get to a hundred percent you're going to just decrease two-thirds more right and so like the more you do it you're approaching a hundred percent chance but you'll never actually reach a hundred percent chance except at infinity right because there's always going to be some chance that you fail every time like it had that chance that possibility has to exist, right?
这是一个很好的观点，也应该指出，如果你像刚才说的那样思考这个公式，随着你越来越接近，你会开始放慢速度，对吧？所以，你每次都在减去一个百分比，但你增加的量会变小。我表达得不太好，基本上，你做了 100 次，得到了三分之二的几率，但如果你再做 100 次，你不会——你不会再次——你不会达到 100%，你只会再增加三分之二的几率，对吧？所以你做得越多，你就越接近 100% 的几率，但你永远无法真正达到 100% 的几率，除非是在无穷大时，对吧？因为总会有某种几率让你每次都失败，那种可能性必须存在，对吧？
And it's a non-zero possibility. That's right. So yeah, if you're curious about this thing, it's the binomial distribution. You can go on Wikipedia, learn all about it. It's pretty interesting. In general, like even if you're not, you know, really into stats,
而且那是一个非零的可能性。没错。所以，如果你对这个感兴趣，这就是二项分布。你可以去维基百科，了解关于它的一切。这很有趣。总的来说，即使你不是真的沉迷于统计学，
just reading about the different distributions is pretty interesting because each one comes from a different phenomena in nature they're all derived from like people's experiences with the world and and just just reading about them is actually like pretty interesting every time I read about statistics I'm reminded how bad I think everyone is pretty bad at it and I think i guess even statisticians probably have to be very conscious in their thought about when they hear things and what they mean because i feel like humans are generally just kind of bad at odds yep yeah totally uh the one that we've
仅仅阅读关于不同分布的知识也很有趣，因为每一种都来自自然界中不同的现象，它们都源于人们对世界的体验，仅仅阅读它们其实就相当有趣。每次我阅读统计学知识时，我都会想起我觉得每个人在这方面都很差劲。我想，即使是统计学家，在听到事情和理解其含义时，可能也必须非常清醒地思考，因为我觉得人类通常对概率的理解比较糟糕。是的，完全正确。我们之前谈过这个，但对于那些可能是第一次收听节目的听众来说，蒙提霍尔问题（Monty Hall problem）总是最好的例子。
talked about it before but for people who this might be their first show or whatever the monty hall problem is always the best example of that, I think. Yeah, although, you know, that one is kind of confusing. So have we talked about it before? Should we give a brief description? We'll recap it. Someone actually emailed me today to say that when we say we said something, we should say it again, if that makes any sense.
是的，虽然那个问题有点令人困惑。我们之前谈过吗？我们要简要描述一下吗？我们会回顾一下。今天确实有人给我发邮件说，当我们说我们说过某事时，如果说得通的话，我们应该再说一遍。
So Monty Hall problem is this. You have three doors uh they tell you that one of the doors has a car the other two doors has something else it's like a goat or something yeah so um you pick a door let's say door number one then what the host does is he picks not the door you picked that's the key point he he had if you say i'm interested in door number one then the host has to choose either door number two or door number three and open it for you but he knows what's behind each door so he will reveal a door with a goat that's right that's right so um so he knows so if there's goats and doors two and three he'll pick one at random 50 50 chance if there's a car in one of those doors he'll pick the goat uh door
所以蒙提霍尔问题是这样的：你有三扇门，他们告诉你其中一扇门里有一辆车，另外两扇门里有别的东西，比如山羊之类的。是的，所以你选了一扇门，假设是 1 号门。然后主持人会做什么呢？他会选择不是你选的那扇门，这是关键点。如果你说我对 1 号门感兴趣，那么主持人必须选择 2 号门或 3 号门并为你打开它。但他知道每扇门后面是什么，所以他会揭示一扇有山羊的门。没错，没错。所以，如果 2 号门和 3 号门后面都有山羊，他会随机选一个，50/50 的几率。如果其中一扇门里有车，他会选有山羊的那扇门。
but the thing is and then he'll come to you and he'll say you you chose door number one i showed you what's behind door number two do you want to stick with your choice or do you want to change choices and we'll reveal what's behind your door and you get whatever's behind your door that's right and so you should change well so the question is does it matter if you stay or like what is the best strategy right and and the answer is, is that you should change your guess. And it seems like doesn't make sense. Like, why should you change it? But the key is that the host can't open the door you chose. And so because he can't do that, he has to choose one of the other two doors and he has to choose a goat door and because of those two things he's giving you information you didn't have before like it seems like he's choosing a door at random but you are actually forcing him to choose a door by you know picking a door in the beginning you're sort of forcing his hand not always but sometimes and the fact that you did that carries some information. So it's one of these like statistical paradoxes, but it's super interesting. You should look it up.
但问题是，然后他会走到你面前说：“你选了 1 号门，我给你看了 2 号门后面是什么，你想坚持你的选择，还是想换一个选择？”然后我们会揭示你门后是什么，你得到你门后的东西。没错。所以你应该换吗？问题是，坚持还是换，哪种策略最好？答案是，你应该改变你的猜测。这看起来似乎没道理。为什么你应该改变它？但关键在于主持人不能打开你选的那扇门。正因为他不能那样做，他必须选择另外两扇门中的一扇，而且他必须选择一扇有山羊的门。由于这两点，他给了你之前没有的信息。看起来他是在随机选择一扇门，但实际上你通过在开始时选择一扇门，强迫他做出选择。你某种程度上是在强迫他，虽然不是总是这样，但有时是这样。你这样做的事实包含了一些信息。所以这是一个统计悖论，但它超级有趣。你应该查一下。
It is really challenging. And even when I know the answer, I still don't find it intuitive. Like I have to reason about it. But the funny thing is the two strategies aren't even close. Like always staying or always switching. Always switching yields significantly better odds than always staying. Yep. And the more doors you have, the better your... I guess it diminishes. But yeah.
这确实很有挑战性。即使我知道答案，我仍然觉得它不直观。我必须进行推理。但有趣的是，这两种策略甚至都不接近。比如总是坚持还是总是切换。总是切换比总是坚持能带来明显更好的几率。是的。而且你拥有的门越多，你的……我想它会减弱。但是的。
Right. That's right. I mean, as the doors go to infinity, then the fact that you forced him not to pick one of them becomes negligible. Right. Okay. infinity then the fact that you forced him not to pick one of them becomes negligible right um okay so i was emailed as well i actually think this was last week or two weeks ago by oh i have it here on the date uh when was this uh oh yeah so a week ago by abdullah and he was saying, or yeah, they're saying that four years ago, so we're in the Olympics now in August. And four years ago was also Olympic time. I guess that would have been
没错。也就是说，当门数趋于无穷大时，你强迫他不能选其中一扇门的事实就变得微不足道了。没错。好的，我也收到了一封邮件，我其实认为这是上周或两周前，由 Abdullah 发来的。他说，或者说，他们说四年前，所以我们现在在八月份的奥运会期间。四年前也是奥运会时间。我想那应该是在伦敦。Jason 对 2016 年奥运会做了一个预测。没错。我预测我们将能够观看，那个叫什么来着？我忘了。有一种东西可以在 BitTorrent 上观看视频。四年前这很火。但想法是，你知道，想想 Netflix，但组成视频的所有数据包都来自互联网上的随机用户。但这会是一个类似 Netflix 的东西。我想它叫 BitTorrent 视频，
in London. And Jason made a prediction about the 2016 Olympics. That's right. I predicted that we would be able to watch, what's it called? I forgot. There's a thing where you can watch videos on BitTorrent. It was like pretty hot four years ago. But the idea is, you know, think of like, you know, Netflix, but it's all of the packets that comprise the video are just coming from random people on the internet. But it would be a Netflix-like thing. I think it's called BitTorrent video,
（接上文）但这会是一个类似 Netflix 的东西。你进去，就开始看视频，但它是众包的。没有人为服务器付费。我当时觉得 2016 年的奥运会会通过这些匿名点对点的东西来播放。但这并没有发生。其实我不认为你甚至可以在没有有线电视订阅的情况下在线观看奥运会。我不这么认为。我肯定你可以看片段，可能还有所谓的“盗版”流媒体。当然，但你无法获得像官方那样的奥运会直播源，这真的很遗憾，因为奥运会的全部意义在于业余体育运动。现在不是了。是的，我的意思是，我四年前确实认为……但我们没有点对点的奥运流媒体，我们有所有这些 NBA 超级巨星，这也挺酷的。
but it's a Netflix-like thing. You go in, you just start watching a video, but it's all crowdsourced. No one's paying for the servers. And I kind of felt like the Olympics in 2016 would be served over one of these, you know, anonymous peer-to-peer kind of things. And it didn't happen actually i don't think can you even watch the olympics online without a without a cable subscription uh i don't think so i'm sure you can watch clips and there's probably like quote-unquote pirate streams sure yeah but you can't get a feed like a official you know olympic feed which is really kind of a shame because the whole point of the olympics is like amateur athletics not anymore um yeah i mean i i kind of thought four years ago that that you know but instead of instead of peer-to-peer olympic streams we have uh um we have all these like
好吧，我以为我会让你措手不及，但显然你对这个预测有预警，所以没关系。也许我会再试一次。所以我的第一篇新闻文章是……请耐心听我说，这可能会有点奇怪。标题是《交互式数独零知识证明》。这是我以前不知道的东西，我当时想：“哇，这很奇怪，这是什么？”然后我点击了它，读了关于它的内容，我当时想：“哇，这太棒了。”
nba superstars which is you know cool too well i thought i was going to blindside you but apparently you had forewarning of of this prediction so that's okay maybe i'll try again so my first news article is uh and bear with me this is going to be a little strange i guess an interactive sudoku zero knowledge proof is the is the title of the article and this is something i didn't know about i was like wow this is weird what is this and then i something I didn't know about. I was like, wow, this is weird. What is this? And then I clicked on it, read about it, and I was like, whoa, this is awesome.
所以如果你……那听起来真的很像冲浪者，我道歉。如果你以前听说过零知识证明，我是在偶然中听到的，通常与区块链之类的东西联系在一起。比如比特币、以太坊之类的。零知识证明是一种你解决问题的方法，例如，我解决了一个问题，我想与 Jason 交流并向他证明我有这个问题的解决方案，
So if you, that sounded really surfer-ish. I apologize. If you've heard of before zero knowledge proof, I kind of heard it in passing, often associated with like blockchain stuff. So Bitcoin and Ethereum and the the like and zero knowledge proof is a way of you solving a problem and for instance like i solve a problem and i want to communicate to jason and prove to him that i have a solution to the problem him to know that i have the solution to the problem
而不需要告诉他这个问题的解决方案。所以，其中一件事就像如果有一个非常大的数字，我已经对这个数字进行了因式分解，你知道，它是一个合数，我已经分解了它，或者它是一个质数，我已经证明了它是质数。我其实不知道它如何与质数一起工作，我只是编造了这一部分。我想与你交流并向你证明我已经完成了这项工作。但我不想在你接受我的证明之前告诉你答案是什么。这有点像你进行此操作的方式。所以在这个例子中，这篇文章实际上链接到了同一作者之前写的一篇关于更通用的零知识证明的文章，但我认为数独的那篇，所以你也应该读读那篇，但零知识数独那篇
without telling him the solution to the problem um so okay so one of the things would be like if there was a really large number and i had factored the number uh you know it was a composite number and i had factored it or it was a prime number and i had proved it was prime. And I actually don't know how it would work with primes. I'm just making this part up. And I wanted to communicate to you and prove to you that I had actually done that work. But I didn't want to communicate to you what the answer was until you accepted my proof. This is this is kind of like a way you would go about doing this. So in this example, and this article actually links to by the same author a previous article they had written about more generally zero knowledge proofs but i thought the sudoku one so you should read that as well but the zero knowledge sudoku one
相当酷，因为它是一个非常容易理解的解释。另一篇通过图着色问题来讲解，这稍微抽象一点。但基本上……好吧，数独是一个图着色问题，对吧？我不知道，如果你告诉我它是，我会同意你的。如果你问我，我不知道。哦，是的，数独是一个图着色问题，你有九种颜色，并且你在所有不能是相同数字的方格之间画边，你知道我的意思吗？哦，好的，虽然它呈现的方式不是图，但你可以把它表示为一个图。我明白了。是的，没错。我以前没那样想过。但我想这说得通。而且，我想数独的规则
was kind of cool because it was a very easy to gasp explanation the other one goes through a graph coloring problem which is a little more abstract but basically well sudoku is a graph coloring problem right uh i don't yeah if you told me it was i would say that would agree with you if you ask me i don't know oh yeah sudoku is a graph coloring problem where you have nine colors and and you draw edges between all of the squares that that can't be the same number you know i'm saying oh okay so it isn't a graph in the way it's presented though it's a but you could represent it as a graph i got it yes yeah yeah right i hadn't thought about it that way before um but i i guess it makes sense um and so but i guess like the rules of sudoku
或者如果你以前玩过数独，这篇文章所做的是解释它，然后实际上有一个……我想我们以前会称之为小程序（applet），但小程序现在已经不是什么东西了，所以……是的，这有点令人难过。实际上我甚至不知道，我想因为小程序不是什么东西了，Flash 也不是什么东西了，所以我猜它一定是 HTML 或 JavaScript。是的。这是什么呢？如果你以前玩过数独，这会是一种方法，给定一个谜题，你知道填入了一些数字，我解决了它并正确填入了所有数字，而且一个正确的数独谜题总有一个唯一的解，只有一个唯一的解。如果我想
or if you've sudoku if you've played it before what this article does is explain it and then actually has like a little I guess we would have called an applet before but applets aren't a thing anymore so it yeah that's kind of sad there's actually I don't even know I guess because applets aren't a thing and flash isn't a thing so I guess so it must I guess it's htmlml or javascript yeah um and what this is is if you've kind of played sudoku before this would be a way given a puzzle and you know a few of the numbers filled in and i solved it and filled in all the numbers correctly and there's always a unique solution to a proper sudoku puzzle only a single unique solution um and i wanted to
与 Jason 交流并让他知道我完成了它，而不给他答案，这会引导你如何做到这一点。它有双方，作为解题者的我这一方，以及作为检查者的 Jason 这一方。我想他们称之为……我的这一方是证明者（prover），我忘了确切的术语是什么。总之，看看这篇文章，它非常有信息量。这是我除了偶然听到这个术语外一无所知的东西。现在我真的很感兴趣。我有点想深入研究一下，了解更多。
communicate that to jason and him to know that i completed it without giving him the answer and this walks through how you would do it and it has both sides like what my side would be as the solver and what jason's side would be as the checker i think they call it mine would be the prover and i forget what the exact terms are anyways check out the article it's really informative And it's something I didn't know anything about other than hearing the term in passing. And now I actually am very intrigued. I kind of want to dig into it a little more and understand.
所以如果你曾经对它感到好奇，或者听说过它，或者以前从未听说过它，我推荐这篇文章。你要么搜索“Interactive Sudoku Zero Knowledge Proof”，要么我们会在节目笔记中提供链接。是的，这真的很酷。我的意思是，他们确实有一个东西，你可以填写一个数独板，它会向你展示如何进行验证，所有步骤都会一步步引导你。是的，所以这个，然后
And so if you've ever been curious about it or heard about it or never heard about it before, I'd recommend this article. You either search Interactive Sudoku Zero Knowledge Proof or we'll link in the show notes. Yeah, this is really cool. I mean, they literally have a thing where you can fill out a sudoku board and it'll show you how to do the verification and everything like it'll step by step walk through it yeah and so this and then
在之前的一篇文章中，他们确实提到了，比如如果我想在区块链中使用托管账户，那会如何工作？我如何让 Jason 知道我拥有的东西是合法的？让他把钱放入托管账户，发送给他，基本上让区块链本身进行经纪业务，这样我们就不必依赖第三方。这也非常有趣。很酷。非常酷。是的，我的新闻是 OpenStreetMap 城市街区。这很酷。OpenStreetMap 的想法是……
in the previous example a previous article they'd written they do mention here like if i wanted to use a escrow account in the blockchain how would that work like how would i have something that i wanted jason to know that what i had was legitimate him put money in the escrow send it to him and and basically have the blockchain itself kind of do the brokering so we don't have to rely on a third party and And that was really interesting as well. Cool. Very cool. Yeah, my news is OpenStreetMap City Blocks. This is pretty cool. The idea is OpenStreetMap.
我们可能之前谈过它。我实际上已经把它用于几个项目了。OpenStreetMap 正如其名，它是所有街道的开源地图。它也做海岸线和森林线以及所有这些东西。所以想象一下，你知道，你有一些很酷的项目，你想计算你所在社区或邮政编码区域内的街道数量之类的。你可以下载你邮政编码区域的 OpenStreetMap 数据集。
We may have talked about it before. I've actually used it for several projects. OpenStreetMap is, as it suggests, it is a open source map of all the streets. And it also does coastal and forest lines and all that stuff. So imagine, you know, you have some cool project where you want to count the number of streets in your neighborhood or in your zip code or something like that. You can download the OpenStreetMap data set for your zip code.
他们甚至有一个小地图视图，你可以画一个小矩形并裁剪出你的社区。你最终会得到这个 XML 文件，你可以解析该文件。他们有一堆工具，你可以计算，比如我的社区有多少条街道？我的社区有多少个交通信号灯？你甚至可以把它们绘制在屏幕上
And they even have a little map view where you could draw a little rectangle and crop out your neighborhood. And you will end up with this XML file and you can parse that file. They have a bunch of tools and you could count, like how many streets are my neighborhood? How many traffic lights are my neighborhood? You can even plot them like on the screen
之类的。所以这个家伙使用了 Python GeoJSON，我其实没听说过 GeoJSON，但我认为它是一种带有地理数据规范的 JSON 格式。他实际上通过 Python 代码演示了如何确定一个区域内的城市街区。这只是那种带有良好可视化效果、工具和源代码的酷炫分步指南之一，教你如何处理任何类型的地图数据。所以如果你喜欢这个，如果那个项目听起来很酷，看看这个家伙的东西。这相当有趣。处理地理空间数据总是很酷，因为它本质上是可视化的，或者我觉得它是，所以你最终总能制作出一张很酷的地图之类的。是的，完全正确。呃，我们一直把这些称为新闻，但我认为我们这周的所有内容都是链接，或者这个月……是的，我的下一个链接实际上
and stuff like that. So this guy used Python GeoJSON, which is, I actually haven't heard of GeoJSON, but I think it's a JSON format with like a spec for GeoData. And he actually walks through with Python code how to determine the city blocks in an area. And it's just one of these kind of cool step-by-step with good visualizations and tools and source code on how to do any type of like mapping data. So if you're into that, if that project sounds cool, check out what this guy has. It's's pretty interesting working with geospatial data is always kind of cool because it kind of is inherently visual or i feel like it is and so you always get to make a cool map or something at the end yep yeah totally uh also we keep calling these news but i think all of ours are links this week so or this month um yeah my next link is actually
已经存在一段时间了，显然，但我以前从未见过它，我非常着迷。把它加入到我需要研究的队列中，或者想在业余时间玩玩的队列中。我确实这样做了，我会说我的电脑上打开了我们上个月谈到的那个谜题竞赛，但我还没去尝试任何一个。我本打算在节目之前做的，但我只是没做。所以我仍然欠大家我尝试解决那些谜题的尝试。好的，很酷。但这些谜题被称为 CryptoPals 密码挑战。这是一组围绕破解密码学的谜题。所以每个人都听说过，例如 SHA1 哈希被破解了，你不应该使用它，因为它不安全。但我敢说我们大多数人不知道那
been around for a while apparently but i had never seen it before and i'm thoroughly fascinated adding it to the queue of things i need to work on uh or want to play with in spare time uh which i did i will say i have open saw my computer the puzzle competition that we talked about last month and i didn't go to any of them yet uh i meant to do it before the show and i just didn't uh so i still owe everyone my attempt at trying to do those puzzles all right cool but these puzzles are called the crypto pals crypto challenge uh and this is a group of puzzles around breaking cryptography so everyone has kind of heard that for instance the sha1 hash is broken and you shouldn't use it like it's not secure um but i i would venture to say most of us don't know what
到底意味着什么。是的，我不知道那意味着什么。我们也知道，比如……哦天哪，我总是忘记它，因为现在我们都是 WPA 了，但在 WPA 和 Wi-Fi 之前是什么？WEP。WEP 加密被破解了。所以这套密码挑战从一些编程任务开始学习，然后通过让你使用你构建的工具来破解加密来建立基础。或者至少这是我从浏览它中得出的结论。你正在进行的攻击和分析的种类，随着你完成它们，复杂性会增加，直到达到某种真实等级，看起来像是真正的加密。所以这些不仅仅是玩具密码方案，这些是真实的东西以及关于它们的解释。所以我感觉
that really means yeah i have no idea what that means we also know like you w oh man i always forget it because now we're all wpa but what was it before wpa and wi-fi wep wep is is encryption is broken um and so these set of crypto challenges uh start out with some programming tasks to learn and then they build up on that by having you break encryption using the tools you've built or at least that's what i gather from kind of skimming it and the kinds of attacks you're doing and analysis you're doing uh increase in complexity as you're working through them um up to some kind of like real grade it seems like an actual encryption so these aren't just toy you know uh cipher schemes these are like real things and explanations about them so i feel like
通过完成它，你会很好地学习攻击方法，甚至可能能够进行你自己的攻击，也了解这些东西本身，因为有什么比通过弄清楚如何破解它来学习加密方案更好的方法呢？所以当他们说“破解”时，他们是指他们发现了一些你可以利用的假设，这样你就不必进行那么多次暴力破解了吗？还是他们是指计算机已经足够快了，以至于它们……你知道，密钥不够长之类的？我认为两种意思都有。在第一种情况下，人们可能会说 32 位 RSA 加密不再安全，他们指的是，有了足够的计算能力，对 32 位加密密钥进行因式分解非常快，以至于你的消息不会保持安全很长时间，或者换句话说，
working through it you would learn really well about both the attacks and maybe even being able to do your own attacks and also about the things themselves, because what better way to learn about an encryption scheme than by figuring out how to break it. So when they say broken, do they mean that they found some assumptions you can make where you don't have to brute force as much? Or do they mean that computers are just fast enough that they're not you know the keys aren't long enough or something i think it means both ways so in the first case people might say that like 32-bit which no one uses it but like 32-bit rsa encryption is no longer secure and what they mean by that is that with enough compute power factoring a 32-bit encryption key is so fast that your message won't stay secure for very long or long enough in other words
它不会持续一百年，只会安全……好吧，32 位真的很短，但这正是他们的意思。但正如你指出的，你也可以检测到一个缺陷。在这种方式下，它不是被“破解”了，它只是不安全。但你也可以发现一个缺陷，这意味着即使你认为你有 X 位的安全性，你也没有，因为有一些缺陷允许某人利用某些东西并找到绕过它的方法。比如，而不是进行因式分解，例如在 RSA 算法中，如果有人发现“哦，你有一个 256 位的数字，但我实际上不需要对这个 256 位的数字进行因式分解，我只需要对这个 8 位的数字进行因式分解”，那么这就有点被破解了。明白了。是的，这说得通。至少这是我的理解。而且这两种方式都有。
instead of lasting a hundred years it would only be secure for maybe well in 32-bit really short but that's kind of what they mean but there's also as you pointed out you could detect a flaw so in that way it's not kind of broken it's just insecure but you could also find a flaw which means that even though you think you have x bits of safety you don't because there's some flaw that allows someone to exploit something and find a way around that uh where instead of factoring so for instance in the rsa algorithm if someone figured out oh you have a 256 bit number but i don't actually need to factor the 256 bit number i only have to factor this 8-bit number instead like then that would be kind of broken got it yeah that makes sense at. At least that's my understanding. And that's kind of both of those ways.
很酷。是的，我得看看这个。我喜欢这样的东西。很酷。是的，我的很简单。所以显然有很多编程语言和新语言一直在出现。随着语言的出现，我想我们很久以前在 Rust 上做过这个，当语言刚出现时，我们通常会在这样的节目中介绍它们，因为我们不知道它们的影响会是什么。这是其中一种语言，它叫 Simit。
Cool. Yeah, I'll have to check this out. I love things like this. Cool. Yeah, mine is pretty simple. So there's obviously a lot of programming languages and new languages coming out all the time. As languages come out, I think we did this with Rust a long time ago, as languages first come out, we usually cover them in something like this because we don't know really what the impact is going to be. And this is one of these languages, it's called Simit.
这是一种用于物理模拟的语言。这很酷。想法是，它都在一台机器上，但它处理这些……那么什么是好的例子呢？让我们拿……它都在一台机器上，但它处理这些。比如，什么是好的例子？让我们拿某种水动力学为例。比如你有水滴，它们在某种物理引擎中四处弹跳，对吧？好吧，你可以开始自己编写代码。你可以说，“哦，我有一个水类，水类会有速度。”然后突然你发现，“哦，我有 30 万个类，我的程序因为处理所有这些类和 30 万次虚函数而崩溃了，”
It's a language for physical simulation. This is pretty cool. The idea is, it's all on one machine, but it handles these... So what's a good example of this? Let's take, you know, it's all on one machine, but it handles these. So like, what's a good example of this? Like, let's take, for example, some type of water dynamics. Like you have droplets of water that are, you know, bouncing around in some physical engine, right? Well, you could start coding this yourself. You could say, oh, I'll have, you know have a water class and the water class will have a velocity. And then all of a sudden you find, oh, I have 300,000 classes and my program is just breaking apart because of handling all these classes and virtual functions 300,000 times
而且你每秒更新它 60 次。这就是很多编程原则在那种大规模、运行速度那么快的情况下失效的地方。所以这就是你真正需要一个既能在架构方面表现出色，又能给你带来惊人性能的人的地方。所以这就是很多这类利基语言重要的地方。所以 Simit 在 CPU 或 GPU 上运行。想法是，你解释特定粒子的动力学，你描述它如何……我说是粒子，但它可以是任何
and you're updating it 60 times a second. That's where sort of a lot of the programming principles kind of fall apart when they're at that huge scale running that quickly. And so that's where you really need somebody who can both be good on the architecture side and also give you incredible performance. And so that's where a lot of these kind of niche languages, that's where they're important. So Simit runs on CPU or GPU. And the idea is you, you know, kind of explain the dynamics for a particular particle and you describe how it, and I'm saying particle, but it could be any,
单位，对吧？然后你描述它如何与其他单位交互，你试图描述这些交互的包络，然后它会分解你的模拟，并尝试在 GPU 或 CPU 上尽可能多的核心上运行它。只要你能像 Simit 那样对你的程序建模……Simit 不会让你在每个元素上做 for 循环之类的，对吧？它有点受限，但只要你能用 Simit 描述你正在构建的东西的动力学，它就快得惊人。它完全碾压了 MATLAB 和 R 以及所有这些其他工具。现在是节目推荐书的时间。我的节目推荐书是一套图画小说，
you know, units, right? And then you describe how that interacts with with other ones you sort of try to describe the envelope of these interactions and then it breaks apart your uh simulation and tries to run it um you know on as many cores as possible on a gpu or cpu and as long as you can model your program like as long as simit um you know like what simit simit can't you know it won't let you do like for loop and do individual things on each element and things like that right it's kind of restricted but as long as you can uh describe the dynamics of what you're building in simit it's insanely fast it like completely blows away um you know matlab and r and and all these other tools time for book of the show book of the show my book of the show is a set of graphic novels which
我发现这是成年人……是老头子说漫画书的方式。但我的是《曼哈顿计划》（The Manhattan Projects），这很酷。想法是……如果大家不知道，曼哈顿计划是原子弹的代号。所以《曼哈顿计划》是一套漫画书，你发现原子弹只是众多曼哈顿计划中的一个。我不会剧透太多，但你知道，通往外星行星的传送门是另一个。这里有各种各样的项目，它涵盖了整个军事机密和科学家，他们既是研究人员，也是军人，还要处理政策，
i found is is the adult is the like the old man way to say comic books but uh mine's called the manhattan projects it's pretty cool uh the idea is um so if everyone doesn't know the manhattan project was the code name for the atomic bomb um so the manhattan projects is a set of comic books where you find out that the atomic bomb was just one of many Manhattan projects. And I'm not going to spoil too much, but, but you know, a portal to, you know, an alien planet is another one. And there's a variety of these projects and it kind of takes the whole like military secret and scientists who, you know, are researchers, but also military and dealing with, you know, policy who you know are researchers but also military and dealing with you know
你知道，你正在构建一些很酷的东西，但同时它又非常危险。它处理了这一点。它里面有一些很棒的引语，非常有趣且具有预言性的引语。我读了整套书，我想有 30 或 40 卷。它真的非常好，强烈推荐。艺术风格很有趣，它相当坚韧。是的，绝对的。我的意思是，这实际上是我们应该提到的一点，你知道，它相当暴力。如果你有像初中、高中的孩子，也许这不合适。好吧，高中可能没问题，但也许这不合适。高中可能没问题。但它不会是你给五岁儿子
policy you know how you're building something so cool but at the same time it's so dangerous it kind of tackles that it has some amazing quotes in it like really kind of funny and prophetic quotes um i read the whole thing i think it's like 30 or 40 volumes it's uh uh it's really really good highly recommended the art style is kind of interesting it's like 30 or 40 volumes it's uh uh it's really really good highly recommended the art style is kind of interesting it's like pretty gritty yeah definitely i mean it's it's that's actually one thing that we should probably mention is you know it's it's pretty kind of violent um if you have like kids in like middle school high school like maybe this wouldn't be the right thing well high school probably fine but like maybe this wouldn't be the right thing. Well, high school, probably fine. But like, yeah, it wouldn't be something you would give to like your five-year-old son
或女儿的东西。但它绝对是仅限成人观看的。你知道，它有很多粗话，有很多暴力，但它真的很酷。这是一本很棒的书。是的，我从来没想过这一点。我想对于我们的书籍推荐，至少是虚构类的，我们可能应该有
or anything. Oh. Or daughter. But it's definitely for adults only. You know, it's got a lot of language, got a lot of violence, but it's really cool. It's a fantastic read. Yeah, I've never thought about that. I guess for our book recommendations, at least the fiction ones, we probably should have
某种分级，比如“儿童友好”。是的，大多数都有分级。我正在努力回想我所有的科幻推荐，看看我是否说了什么。没关系，我不用担心。不，我的意思是亚马逊会立刻告诉你分级。所以我的本周书籍是《剑之窃》（Theft of Swords）。这很有趣，因为我猜它是一卷。我不知道它们最初是如何发行的。我没有深入研究，因为我尽量不在读完一本书之前读太多关于它的内容，
some sort of like rating uh kid approved yeah well most of them have most of them have a rating i'm trying to think back to all of my sci-fi recommendations and seeing if i've said anything okay it's all right i can't i can't worry about it no i mean amazon i'll tell you right away the rating. So my book of the week is Theft of Swords. This is interesting because I guess it's a volume. I don't know how they were originally released. I haven't looked into it because I try not to read too much about a book
但书里有两本书，每一本都相当独立。所以我猜它是一卷，里面有两个故事，它们是相关的，但你可以在书的一半停下来，也会觉得它是一个完整的故事。我还没完全读完，我可能离书的结尾还有 5% 的进度，但我仍然要推荐它，除非我下周或下个月回来，发现结尾太糟糕了，完全不值得。除此之外，我觉得这是一本非常好的书。很酷。所以这是一本关于……哦，我总是努力不剧透太多，关于两个小偷，他们某种程度上
until I've read it yet. But there's been two books within the book and each one has been pretty self-contained. So I guess it's a volume and there were kind of two stories in it um and they were related but you could have kind of stopped halfway through the book and like been happy it was a story um and i'm not quite done with it yet i'm probably like five percent away from the end of this book but i still am going to recommend it unless like i come back
在一起工作，被卷入了一些事情，有人试图利用他们，但结果并没有像他们想要的那样发生。他们被卷入了一些政治活动，关于他们在这种政治阴谋世界中作为小偷的故事。这很有趣。很酷。
next week or next month and i'm just the ending was atrocious and totally not worth it. Other than that, I feel like it was a really good book. Um, cool. So this is a fantasy book about, Oh, I always struggled to not give away too much about two thieves who are kind
听起来棒极了。所以这是一本轻松的书，我一直在 Audible 上听它，Audible 是我们节目的赞助商。所以如果你有兴趣获得 Audible 订阅，我用它来打发上班路上的时间，我已经是一个付费订阅者……我甚至不知道多久了，好几年了。但如果你去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以获得一个月的免费试用，这基本上是一本书。然后在那之后，你知道，各种计划，如果你不喜欢，你可以取消它并保留你的书。
of working together and get caught up into, uh, something that someone is trying to use them, but it turns out not to happen as they wanted. And they get kind of tied up into some political goings on and kind of their something that someone is trying to use them, but it turns out not to happen as they wanted. And they get kind of tied up into some political goings on and kind of their story about being thieves in this world of political intrigue. It's kind of interesting. Cool.
这有助于支持节目。我确实推荐 Audible。如果你有通勤时间，人们总是在寻找打发时间的方法。我用它来打发通勤时间，我绝对推荐 Audible。我喜欢它。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，关于这些东西，Audible 和我们没有任何协议。
Sounds awesome. So it's a lighthearted book and I've been listening to it on audible and audible is a sponsor of our show. So if you're interested in getting audible subscription which i use to pass my drive to work i've been a paying subscriber for i don't even know how long now several years um but if you go to audible trial.com programming throwdown you can get a one month free which is essentially one book um and then after that you know the various plans and if you don't like it you can just cancel it and keep your book.
我们有……如果你去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，你会帮助支持节目，我们有那个，但我们不是那种只会推销我们自己不用的东西、书籍和服务的托儿。所以，Audible 很酷，去看看吧。我们还有 Patreon。我答应过大家我会制作 T 恤，这样你们就可以订购 T 恤。我在这方面完全拖延了。
And that helps out the show. And I actually do recommend Audible. If you have a commute, people are always looking for ways to pass it. And I pass the time in the commute. And I definitely recommend Audible. I like it. Yeah, totally. I mean, the thing about these things, like Audible doesn't like have any deal with us.
不是我没在做，而是我对标志不满意，我有点完美主义。但一旦我有了好的标志，我们就会做一些 T 恤。我们要找模特吗？因为我觉得你和我当模特不会卖得出去。哦，好观点。
Like we have, if you go to audible trial.com slash porting throw down you will help out the show like we have that but you know we're not like shills who uh you know we only endorse things books and and and services that we actually use so um so yeah audible is cool check it out so we also have Patreon I promised everyone I would get t-shirts made so that we could so you could order t-shirts I'm totally lacking on that
是的，我们需要模特。好吧，你觉得我们能让 Michael Phelps 穿我们的 T 恤吗？那会很棒。唯一的问题是他身上有那些拔罐留下的褐色斑点。所以，是的。所以我们有 Patreon。你去 patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。
it's not that I'm not working on it it's that I'm not happy with the logo and I'm kind of a perfectionist but once I have a good logo we'll get some t-shirts are we going to get models for them? Because I feel like you and I modeling them will not sell them. Oh, good point.
那就像是一笔捐款。它让节目继续下去。我能够买一个麦克风，所以我没有用我在旧货店买的那个麦克风，正如 Reddit 上有人准确指出的那样。所以它帮助我们获得了保持节目运行所需的设备、所有服务等等，所以我们很感激。本期节目的工具。我的工具是……所以最初，或者不是最初，但几个月前，
Yeah, we need models. All right. Do you think we could get Michael Belps to wear one of our T-shirts? That would be pretty awesome. The only thing is he's got those brown spots from those suction cup things. So, yeah. So we have Patreon. You go to patreon.com slash programming throwdown.
我推荐了 ByWord，我确实喜欢 ByWord，但它有一个问题，就是它只支持 OS X 和 iOS，这很好，直到你有一台像我家里台式机那样仍然运行 Windows 的机器。所以 Google Docs 和 ByWord 很接近，但我对 Google Docs 的主要批评是它不是 Markdown。所以如果我想把 Google Docs 里的东西发布到网上或用它做别的事情，它的格式不太容易访问。好吧，有人写了 GDocs2MD，这是一个……我还没试过。我今天晚些时候会试一下。
And that is just like a donation. It keeps the show going. I was able to buy a microphone, so I didn't have a microphone that I got in a thrift shop as someone accurately called me out on on Reddit. So it helps us you get the equipment we need to keep the show going and all the services and all that so we appreciate that long tool this show my tool this show is um so originally or not originally but a few months
但它会获取任何 Google Doc。它是一个小的 Chrome 扩展程序。它会获取任何 Google Doc 并将其转换为 Markdown。所以我一直很喜欢 Google Docs，除了这个问题。很多人说这个插件效果很好，所以是的，绝对……
ago i i recommended by word and i do like by word but um it has this problem where it's OS X and iOS only which is great until you have a machine like my home desktop is still running Windows and so Google Docs is pretty close to ByWord but my big criticism of Google Docs was that it's not Markdown and so if I want to take something from Google Docs and post it on the web or do something else with it, it's not in a format that's very accessible. Well, someone wrote GDocs2MD, which is a – and I haven't tried it yet. I'm going to try it later on today.
如果你有任何笔记，如果你试图写一本书之类的，或者如果你在课堂上做笔记之类的，Google Docs 是最好的选择。它是真正通用的。我本期的工具这次不是游戏，通常是游戏，但我猜你可以说它是 Scrapey，就像 Scrap 后面加个 Y。这是最后的 PY，代表 Python。
But it will take any Google Doc. It's a little Chrome extension. It will take any Google Doc and convert it to Markdown and so I've always been a big fan of Google Docs other than this one issue and this seems to you know a lot of people are saying that this plugin works really well so yeah so definitely you know
这是一个 Python 的网络爬虫或网页抓取工具，一个帮助你编写爬取网络的 Python 程序的库。我以前见过这个，总是说：“哦，我想在某个时候学习它。”在我那堆巨大的研究清单中，它从队列变成了堆，但我最终有了使用它的用例。
if you have any notes if you're trying to write like a book or anything like that or if you're taking notes, if you're trying to write a book or anything like that, or if you're taking notes in class or something, Google Docs is the way to go. It's truly universal. My tool of the show is not a game this time, which it normally is, but I guess you say it's Scrapey, which is like scrap with a Y on the end. And this is the PY at the end for Python.
如果你有任何笔记，或者你正试图写书之类的东西，又或者你在课堂上做笔记，Google Docs 是最好的选择。它确实是通用的。本期节目的工具推荐这次不是游戏，虽然通常是游戏，但我猜你可以称它为 Scrapey，也就是 scrap 后面加个 Y。这里的 PY 是 Python 的意思。
And this is a web crawler or web scraper for Python, a library to help you write Python programs that crawl the web. I'd seen this before and always said, Oh, I wanted to, you know, I want to learn that at some point again, in my giant heap of things, it switched from a queue to a heap, but by heap of things of, you know, to research, but I ended up with the use case for this.
这是一个用于 Python 的网络爬虫，是一个帮助你编写爬取网页的 Python 程序的库。我以前见过它，总是说，哦，我想，你知道，我以后一定要学学这个，在我的那一堆待研究事项中——它已经从队列变成了堆——但我最终还是找到了它的用例。
And I will caution that you should probably read the like user license agreement, you know, respect whatever websites say for proper usage. And please don't take anything I say as like legal advice or not. That was my disclaimer. But I had a use, I wanted to find out what realtor was selling the most property in my area. And, you know, you can go on the website, you can look in your zip code, you can see what realtors are selling houses, selling houses at least in the
我要提醒你，你可能应该阅读一下用户许可协议，你知道的，尊重网站关于正确使用的任何规定。请不要把我说的任何话当作法律建议。这就是我的免责声明。但我有一个用途，我想找出我所在地区哪位房地产经纪人卖出的房产最多。你知道，你可以访问网站，查看你的邮政编码，你可以看到哪些房地产经纪人在卖房子，至少在美国，卖房子是需要披露的，原因有很多，嗯，所以你可以看到房子什么时候卖掉的，这算是公共知识，实际上它们卖了多少钱也是公开的，通常还会列出买家和卖家，以及代表他们的买方和卖方经纪人，嗯，我想看看谁在那个地区卖了很多房子，因为你知道，如果我想卖掉我的房子，我只是好奇谁会是一个好的联系人，是的，完全有道理，但这并不是他们因为各种原因愿意分享的信息，或者他们没有提供这些信息，嗯，是的，他们害怕那种赢家通吃的局面，对吧？
united states is something that needs to be disclosed for various reasons um and so you can see when houses are sold that that's kind of public knowledge and actually how much they're sold for as well it typically also lists the buyer and seller as people as well as the buyer and sellers agents that represented them um and i wanted to see who was selling a lot of houses in the area because you know if i you know i wanted to sell my house i was just curious who would be someone good to contact yeah totally it makes sense but this isn't information that they for various reasons i could imagine they don't want to share or they don't have available um yeah they're afraid of like a winner take all thing, right?
是的。是的。所以它是可用的。你可以手动操作。你可以输入你的邮政编码，或者按地区搜索，查看每一栋房子，并记录下是谁在卖房子以及卖了多少钱。你可以建立这个数据库。但这正是网络爬虫所做的。所以网络爬虫，你给它一个网页，告诉它要在那个网页上寻找什么数据，
Right. Yeah. And so it's available. You could do it by hand. You could kind of enter your zip code or, you know, search by area and kind of look at every one of the houses and kind of keep notes of who was selling houses and how much for it. And you could kind of build this data. But that's what a web crawler does. So a web crawler, you give it a web page and you tell it kind of what data to look for on that web page,
其中之一就是一堆链接，比如该地区已售出的房屋。然后它会去抓取这些页面，把它们也拉下来，并向你的程序展示该网站的代码。然后你可以从中收集任何你想要的信息。所以 Scrapy 实际上是一个非常强大的工具，我只需要基础教程
one of which would be a bunch of links like to houses that had sold in the area. And then it'll go crawl those pages, pull them down as well, and present to your program the code for that website. And then you can collect whatever information you want out of it. And so Scrapey is actually a very powerful tool, and I only needed the basic tutorial
就能让它工作，所以我肯定我甚至还没有触及它的皮毛，它支持所有这些活动。所以它知道如何访问网站。它知道如何获取数据，将其拉入它使用 XPath 或 CSS 过滤器的方式，以便你能够寻找网站中的特定标签，找到 URL 或找到 DOM 的一部分。然后你可以解析这些内容，对它们做些什么，直到“嘿，去抓取这些其他页面”。你的代码会得到一个非常干净的数据切片。然后它有一种方法可以将所有这些数据输出，例如 JSON。所以我所做的是，或者我朋友所做的，我想，我看到一个朋友做了这个，把它全部放进一个 JSON 文件里。一旦你把它放进 JSON 文件里，你就拥有了你需要的所有数据。你只需要做一次。然后我就可以按照我朋友想要的方式对数据进行切片和切块。它可以被切片和切块，你可以排序，你可以看到谁卖出的总金额最高，谁卖出的房屋中位数价格是多少，所有这些信息。它真的很强大。
to even get this working, so I'm sure I didn't even scratch the surface, that supports all of these activities. So it knows how to go to a website. It knows how to get the data, pull it into a way it uses XPath or CSS filters for you to be able to kind of look for specific tags in the website, to find a URL or to find parts of the DOM. And then you can parse those do something with it until Oh, hey, go scrape these other pages. And your code kind of gets a very clean slice of the data. And then it has a way to kind of output all that data to, for instance, JSON. And so what I did was, or a
而且达到这一步真的非常非常快。我朋友编写这段代码并没有花太长时间，因为这个工具真的很棒。所以 Scrapy，如果你需要做类似的事情，它非常强大。它里面有各种各样的先进功能，比如创建数据管道来处理，以及如何创建在管道中移动时得到改进的对象。而且它确实，例如，同一个链接可能会在网页中出现多次。它知道如何不抓取同一个网页两次。所以它会进行去重。
friend did, I guess, I saw a friend who did this, put it all to a JSON file. And then once you had it in a JSON file, you had all the data you needed. You just needed to do it once. And then I could kind of slice and dice the data however my friend wanted. It could be sliced and diced and you could sort, you could see who sold total dollar value the most houses, what was the median price of houses they sold, all this kind of information. It was really powerful.
哦，是的。没有覆盖。是的。所以这只是，我想你刚刚为任何高中生或大学生在选择专业时提供了有史以来最好的背书，你知道我的意思，如果你在学计算机科学，我的意思是，显然所有的专业都很棒，但如果你在学计算机科学，看看你的生活有多酷，你只是自动地说，哦，我想我只是要写一个程序来抓取网络，找到最称职的房地产经纪人，你就像在指尖拥有了令人难以置信的权威和力量，这真是太神奇了，而且有趣的是，一旦我写好了它，就很容易说，而且你就像在指尖拥有了令人难以置信的权威和力量。这真是太神奇了。
And it was actually really, really quick to get there. It didn't take very long for my friend to code this up because this tool is really good. So Scrapey, if you ever need to do something like that, very powerful. It has all sorts of advanced functionality in there about like creating a pipeline of data to go through and how to create objects that get improved as you're moving down the pipeline. And it does, for instance, often the same link may appear more than once in the web page. And it knows how to not kind of scrape that web page twice. So it'll do de-duping.
而且有趣的是，一旦我写好了它，就很容易说，哦，那邻近的邮政编码呢？那另一个州呢？那对吧？然后你就可以开始说，哦，有趣。我想知道如果我有一个邮政编码列表，哪些邮政编码的房屋销售额最高，或者，你知道，随便什么。是的。我的意思是，如果你想买一个稳定的，如果你想在一个稳定的社区买房，你完全可以这样做，你可以字面上看到每个社区的趋势，然后你就可以开始思考，我的意思是，我没有走那么远，但是
Oh, yeah. No clobber. Yeah. So this is just, I think you just gave the best endorsement ever for anyone who is in high school or college and trying to pick their major like you know i mean if you're in cs like i mean obviously all the majors are great but if you're in cs i mean look how cool your life is like you just you just like automatically say oh i think i'm just gonna write a program to scrape the web and find like the most competent realtor and like you just have like incredible authority and power at your fingertips it's just amazing and the thing that's interesting as well is like once i wrote it it was very easy to say And like you just have like incredible authority and power at your fingertips. It's just amazing.
你开始思考，有人说，哦，这是一个好主意，你应该把那些数据发布到某个地方，我想如果我朋友那样做，肯定会违反任何条款，哦，是的，你会违反底层数据的条款，所以不要那样做，那肯定会违反任何
And the thing that's interesting as well is like once I wrote it, it was very easy to say, oh, what about for neighboring zip codes? What about for another state? What about right? And then you can start to say, oh, interesting. I wonder for if I had a list of zip codes for which zip codes are the highest houses selling or, you know, whatever. Yeah. I mean, if you wanted to buy a stable, if you want to buy in like a stable neighborhood you could just do it like you could you could literally like see the trends of each neighborhood and then you could start thinking i mean and i didn't get this far but
每个月，针对上个月，并随着时间的推移建立趋势，随着数据量的增长，这将证明更有用，比如哪个月是卖房的最佳月份，有这样的普遍趋势，但你需要针对一个非常具体的区域，一个非常具体的需求。所以回到 Jason 的观点，在计算机科学领域这很酷，但 Scrapy 看起来真的很强大。我想我将来可能会想到更多的用途
you start thinking and someone was like oh this is a great idea you should you know publish that data somewhere and i think that would definitely for my friend to do that would be definitely against whatever terms oh yeah you would for the underlying data so do not do that would be definitely against whatever
只是想给那个项目点个赞。酷。是的，我肯定会。我通常使用带有 -R 参数的 Wget，但 Scrapy 听起来好多了，所以我也会切换，是的，所以我的意思是这是一个有趣的观点，你可以手工编写我刚才说的所有内容，那并不难，你甚至可以拼凑一些库来帮助你，但最棒的事情是双重的，一是他们已经为我做了所有这些，所以我只需要像它那样的
every month for the last month and building up trends over time that would prove even more useful to you as the amount of data grew like what month is the best to sell in and there's general trends like that but you want it for a very specific area, a very specific tailored need. And so to Jason's point, this is cool being in CS, but the Scrapey seems really powerful. I think I've probably come up with more uses in the future
管道都在那里，所以我总共花了也许，那是因为我以前从未使用过它，而且我不是一个真正的 Python 大程序员，但我可能总共花了三个小时，从有这个想法到使用 Pandas，再到真正按照我想要的方式切分数据，嗯，所以能够得到那个真的很强大，而且他们有教程，你知道，如果你自己做 Wget，你有点孤立无援，但有了 Scrapy，我的意思是这是一个致力于做这些事情的社区，所以很容易找到答案，非常酷，非常酷，好了，所以我们的节目主题是优化，显然有很多组成部分。
and just wanted to give a shout out to that project. Cool. Yeah, I will definitely. I usually use Wget with dash R, but Scrapey sounds way better so i will switch yeah so so i mean that's an interesting point you could write all of that what i just said by hand it wouldn't be that hard and you could cobble together a few libraries to even help you but the awesome thing was twofold one is that they already did all of that for me so i only had to like it the kind of
所以我们尝试从尽可能接近底层开始，然后一直向上移动到堆栈。所以我想最低层应该是，你知道，只是指令集和架构。是的，所以我认为，你知道，
the plumbing was all there so i banged this out in a total of maybe and that was because i'd never used it before and i'm not a real big python programmer but i probably banged it out in a total of three hours from like having the idea to using pandas to actually like slice the data in the way i wanted um and so that was really powerful to get that and they have tutorials you know kind of devoted like if you're doing w get on your own you're kind of on your own a little but with scrapie i mean this is a community of people devoted to doing these kinds of things and so it's really easy to find answers very cool very cool all right so our show uh topic is optimization and uh there's obviously like many components to that.
我对底层更熟悉。所以我认为我可能会在开始时多说一点，然后当我们向上移动堆栈时，我们可能会转向 Jason。好的。但完全正确。所以指令，所以你稍微构思了一下，但优化是一个非常广泛的话题。我们将尝试为你提供一些流行语、关键词供你参考，以及一些需要思考的事情。如果你曾经遇到需要让你的程序运行得更快，或者你的软件堆栈运行得更快的情况，你应该考虑哪些事情？
So we try to start with, you know, close to the metal as possible and then move all the way up the stack. So I guess like the lowest level would be, you know, just the, you know, the instruction set and the architecture you're working with. Yeah, so I think, you know,
在每个层面上，都有一定的工作可以完成。不同的层面适用于不同类型的项目，项目生命周期的不同部分。所以我们将以相当高的速度浏览这个过程。但第一件事是你使用的处理器，
I'm more comfortable low level. So I think I'll probably talk a lot here in the beginning and then we'll probably shift over to Jason as we move up the stack here. All right. But exactly right. So the instructions, so you kind of framed it a little, but optimization is really broad topic. We're going to try to kind of give some buzzwords, keywords for you to look at and some things to think about. If you ever encounter needing to make your program run faster or your software stack to run faster, what are the kinds of things you should be thinking about?
架构，无论是微处理器还是 x86 处理器，ARM 处理器，你可用的指令都会有所不同。如果你有能力选择你运行的架构，你可能能够获得某些优势。例如，有趣的一件事是桌面英特尔处理器和服务器英特尔处理器之间的区别，如果你从高层看它们，时钟速度可能相同，核心数量可能相同，
And at every level, there's some amount of work that you can be done. And different levels are appropriate for different kinds of projects, different parts of the life cycle of a project. And so we're gonna kind of cruise through this on a pretty high speed. But the first thing is the processor you're using,
但两者可用的指令集可能大不相同，支持的同时浮点运算数量可能在家庭和服务器之间有很大不同，这解释了两者之间的大部分价格差异，了解你拥有哪一个以及你正在运行哪一个将帮助你为正确的事情优化你的程序。是的，当你查看兆赫时，你知道你的处理器，你只是在查看执行最快的一件事所需的速度，但你知道一个处理器可能拥有只有一半的兆赫，但带宽却是两倍，所以如果假设你可以并行化你的计算，那么它们是等效的，即使其中一个从表面上看要高得多。所以我看到了一个很好的例子，有人说对于
the architecture, whether it's a microprocessor or an x86 processor, an ARM processor, the instructions available to you are going to be different. And if you have the ability to choose what kind of architecture you're running on, you may be able to get certain advantages. One the things that's interesting for instance is what is the difference between a desktop intel processor and a server intel processor um if you look at them kind of like at a high level the clock speed might be the same the number of cores might be the same
最新的英特尔处理器，高端英特尔处理器非常昂贵。所以他们实际上购买了 Xeon，这是服务器级英特尔处理器，并进行了一些比较。Xeon 处理器在相同的价格范围内碾压了消费市场的最新英特尔处理器。但区别在于，如果你玩电子游戏，Xeon 处理器实际上非常糟糕，因为它们都是关于一次做很多小事情，这在服务器中你会这样做，
but the instruction sets available in the two can be vastly different and the amount of simultaneous floating point operations supported right can be very different between a home and a server and explains you know a lot of the price difference between those two and understanding which one you have and which one you're running on will help you optimize your program for the right thing yep yeah when you look at megahertz you know your processor you're only looking at the speed it takes to do the fastest one thing um but you know a processor could have you know half the megahertz but twice the bandwidth and so then they're you know assuming you can parallelize um you know your computation then they're equivalent, even though one looks a lot higher at, you know, superficially. So I saw a great example of this, someone said for the
服务于许多许多页面请求。但在游戏中，你只是想尽可能快地做一两件事，是的，所以这是一个有趣的权衡。另一件事是我们已经讨论过几次了，所以我们会略过它，但 GPU，所以进入异构处理，以及你是否可以使用 GPU 来卸载并优化你的程序运行时，通过在那里运行它，然后你知道，一旦你选择了 CPU 或 GPU 架构，你就可以开始谈论编译器，它正在为特定架构生成代码，并且编译器中有各种各样的优化设置，
newest Intel processors, like high end Intel processors were pretty expensive. And so they actually bought Xeon, which is the server class Intel processors and kind of did a comparison. And the Xeon processors crushed the newest Intel processor for the consumer market, kind of in the same price range. But the difference is if you played a video game, the Xeon process were actually pretty terrible because they were all about doing lots of little things at once, which you would do in a server,
所以你可以针对大小与速度进行优化，其中一个有趣的事情，我们稍后会讲到，是你可能会说，好吧，为什么我不直接针对大小进行优化？因为大多数时候我们不关心，或者为什么我们不直接针对速度进行优化？大多数时候，我们真的不关心程序的大小。但如果你看看处理器是如何工作的，它必须将程序的某些部分保留在内存中。所以如果你有某部分代码被反复使用，如果编译器试图通过这些指令一次性优化它以尽可能快地运行，它可能会有一个代码大小，比它针对大小进行优化时大 25%
serving up many, many page requests. But on a game, you're kind of only wanting to do one or two things as fast as possible yeah and so that was an interesting trade-off other thing is we've talked about several times so we'll skim over it but gpu so get into heterogeneous processing and whether you can use a gpu to offload uh and optimize how your process your your program's runtime by running it there and then you know once you have a cpu selected or a gpu architecture you can start to talk about the compiler which is producing code for a specific architecture and there's all sorts of optimization settings in your compiler
。如果大小让你低于缓存的限制，并且你可以将程序保留在缓存中而不是主内存中，那么通过针对大小而不是速度进行优化，你实际上可能会更快，这真的很令人困惑。哇，我不知道会发生这种情况。是的，我们遇到过几次这种情况，这真的很难预测，而且取决于你运行的处理器。
so you can optimize for size versus speed and one one of the interesting things, and we'll get to this in a second, is that you might say, well, why wouldn't I just do size? Because most of the time we're not concerned about, or why wouldn't we just do speed? Most of the time, we're just not really concerned about the size of our program. But if you look at how a processor works, it has to keep parts of your program in memory. And so if you have a certain portion of your code, which is used over and over again, if the compiler tries to optimize it to run as fast as possible, through those instructions once, it might have a code size, which is 25%
但你只需要尝试两者。但优化编译器会尝试为你做各种技巧，比如将变量保留在寄存器中而不是内存中。它可以做一些复杂的事情，比如循环展开。所以如果你认为你有一个 for 循环，并且你只会遍历它一次或两次，你知道一些定义在它上面的常量，但像两次一样，你需要遍历这个循环两次或三次，如果你在汇编中把它写成一个循环，那么你就有这个分支，所以在 for 循环处你必须首先
bigger than if it optimizes for size. And if the size gets you under the limit of one of your caches and you can keep your program loaded in cache instead of in main memory, then you actually might be faster by having it be optimized by speed, which is by size than by speed, which is really kind of confusing. Wow, I had no idea that that could happen. Yeah, so we've had this happen a couple times and it's really kind of hard to predict and it depends on exactly what processor you're running on.
评估一些条件，如果满足条件，你必须首先评估一些条件。如果满足条件，你需要执行下面的指令。否则，你需要分支跳过 for 循环的末尾进入其他代码。但进行比较和分支是两件消耗处理器时间的事情。分支是因为流水线，我们现在不讨论它，比较是因为那是它必须执行的指令。如果你总是要执行那个循环三次，而不是必须评估，你知道，计数器 i 是否小于 3，你可以直接在循环内连续运行相同的代码三次，中间有一个递增的计数器值。然后你节省了运行 for 循环处理部分的开销。所以这是编译器可以做的事情，试图
But you kind of just got to try both. But Optimize the compiler will try to do a variety of tricks for you about keeping your variables in registers instead of in memory. It can do things that are complicated like loop unrolling. So if you think about you have a for loop and you're only going to go through it once or twice you know some constant that's defined on it once but like two times like you need to go through this loop two times or three times if you kind of write it in assembly as a loop then you have this branch so at the for loop you have to first
优化你的代码。有时编译器不知道可以这样做。你需要手动完成。而且你实际上需要，这很极端。我不建议从那里开始作为优化设置。但有时你可能会通过手动展开循环获得好处。是的，我前段时间看到一篇文章说，我的意思是，我觉得这是一个非常牵强的例子，但他们说在某些情况下，Java 比 C++ 更快，因为他们有这种即时编译器。所以运行时，它可以知道这个 for 循环只会执行 50 次，即使 50 是一个变量，嗯，你知道，当它到达 for 循环时，它知道它只会是 50
evaluate some condition if the condition is met you have to first evaluate some condition. If the condition is met, you need to execute the instructions below. Otherwise, you need to branch past the end of the for loop into the other code. But doing that comparison and branching are two things that cost the processor time. The branching because of pipelining, which we won't get into now, and the comparison because that's an instruction it has to perform. If you are always going to execute that loop three times, instead of having to evaluate, you know, the counter i is less than three or not, you could just run the same code inside the loop three consecutive times with an increasing counter value in between. And then you save the overhead of running the for loop processing part. And so that's something that compiler can do to try to
保证，所以它展开了循环，这是 C++ 无法做到的，我不知道今天这有多少真实性，这也是一篇旧文章，但这确实发生了，实际上人们不知道，我遇到过一些人，他们不知道这一点，这让他们感到震惊。处理器本身也会学习所谓的分支预测。是的。所以如果你有一个 if 语句，
optimize your code. And sometimes the compiler doesn't know that can be done. And you need to do it by hand. And you actually need to like, that's pretty extreme. I wouldn't recommend kind of starting off there as an optimization setting. But sometimes you may gain benefit by hand unrolling your loops. Yeah, I saw some article a while back that said, I mean, I feel like this is a very contrived example, but they said that in some cases, Java was faster than C++ because they have this just in time compiler. And so at runtime, it could know that this for loop is only going to be executed 50 times even though the 50 was a variable um you know by the time it got to the for loop it knew that it was only going to be 50
例如，如果代码抛出了异常，你知道，进行错误处理。否则，你知道，继续，编译器，处理器本身，当它在运行你的代码时，会学习到那个分支从未被采用。所以它总是可以被采用，但它会乐观地假设它不会被
guaranteed and so it unrolled the loop which is something c++ couldn't do um i don't know how much truth there is to that today this is also an old article but that that does happen and actually people don't, I've met people who, who kind of didn't know this and it was shocking to them. The processor itself also will learn in what's called branch prediction. Yeah. So if you have an if statement,
采用。然后它会开始用之后的代码填充流水线，而不是异常内部的代码。所以当你一次又一次地遍历那个循环时，你会获得更好的速度。然后如果你确实抛出了异常，它会稍微慢一点，因为代码没有预料到会发生这种情况。是的。而且讽刺的是，处理器这样做的方式是通过估计二项分布，这是我们在本集开头讨论的第一件事。所以它向后推。它说，基于你多少次采用或未采用这个分支，我将某种程度上反向工程置信界限。然后当
for instance, if the code has thrown an exception, you know, do error handling. Otherwise, you know, kind of continue on the compile, the processor itself, as it, do error handling, otherwise, you know, kind of continue on. The compiler, the processor itself, as it's running your code, will learn that that branch is never taken. So it always could be taken, but it will optimistically assume that it won't be
它达到一定数量时，它就开始做，它交换了预测。这也与我们之前讨论的保持代码尽可能紧凑有关，特别是在你需要进行许多许多迭代时。所以例如，考虑一下如果你需要进行图像处理并对图像中的每个像素进行某种操作。如果你保持那段代码非常小，那么编译器就有更好的机会了解那些分支，或者不是编译器，而是处理器有更好的机会了解那些分支，是的，所以我之前提到了缓存级别，所以当处理器规格化时，人们听说过 L1、L2、L3 缓存大小，然后你有 RAM 大小，然后你有 RAM 大小，然后你有磁盘。
taken. And then it'll start loading the pipeline with the code afterwards, instead of the code inside the exception. And so as you go through that loop more and more times, you'll get better speed. And then if you ever do throw an exception, it'll be slightly slower because the code, it wasn't anticipating that was going to happen. Yeah. And ironically, the way the processor does that is by estimating the binomial distribution, which is the first thing we talked about in the episode. So it goes backwards. And it says, based on how many times you did or didn't take this branch, I'm going to sort of reverse engineer the confidence bounds. And then when
所以因为光速，如果你必须一直从处理器走到主内存，你需要行进的距离实际上变得相当显著。所以无论你的 RAM 变得多快，数据进入处理器的速度仍然会有一个限制，仅仅是因为它必须通过电线行进多远，是光速还是速度，嗯，光速设定了一个理论界限，哦，明白了，对吧，所以即使你使用光纤或任何东西，如果你离处理器一米远，这是一种极端情况，那么你知道，从你决定需要某样东西到你从某样东西那里得到它的最快速度，有一个设定的延迟，
it gets to a certain amount, then it starts doing, it swaps over the prediction. And this also has to do with what we were talking about before keeping your code kind of as compact as possible, especially when there's many, many iterations you need to do. So for instance, think about if you needed to do image processing and do some operation for every pixel in the image. If you keep that code very small, then the compiler has a better chance of learning about those branches or not the compiler but the processor has a better chance of learning about those branches yeah and so then i mentioned before cache levels so people have heard things when processors are spec'd out like l1 l2 l3 cache sizes and then you have ram size and then you have RAM size, and then you have disk.
那么远。当你谈论千兆赫时，这实际上很重要，当我第一次学到这一点时，这很疯狂。但撇开这一点不谈，那不是主要问题。最大的问题是拥有非常非常快的内存并将其放在处理器本身上是非常昂贵的，所以你离执行代码的处理器主要部分越近，你就越小，因为物理处理器上有很多东西需要连接，而且空间确实不多，所以你必须通过额外的接口集，并到达芯片的其他部分以获得更大级别的缓存，所以处理器总是想在最近的缓存中查找，因为如果它不在那里，那个缓存是最快的，
So because of the speed of light, the amount of distance you need to travel actually becomes fairly significant if you have to go all the way out from your processor to main memory. So no matter how fast your RAM ever gets, there will still be a limit to how fast data can come into the processor just because of how far it has to go travel through the wires does the wire is it the speed of light or is it the speed well the speed of light sets a theoretical bound oh okay got it right so even if you use fiber optics or whatever if you're like a meter away from the processor which is an extreme then you know kind of there's a set latency from when you decide you need something to the fastest you could get it from something
你就会遇到所谓的缓存未命中，然后你必须去下一个缓存未命中，去下一个缓存未命中，去主内存，如果它不在主内存中，它必须去下一个。缓存，未命中，去下一个。缓存，未命中，去主内存。如果它不在主内存中，它必须一直去硬盘，这太糟糕了。这意味着在处理器中需要永远。是的，我想每一步都是一个数量级，对吧？或者数量级，是的。哦，哇。所以这真的很糟糕，对吧？所以当我们谈论优化时，一旦你了解了处理器的工作方式，你可以做很多事情。
that far away. And when you're talking gigahertz, that actually matters, which is crazy when I first learned that. But leaving that aside, that's not the main problem. The biggest issue is it is very expensive to have very, very fast memory and to put memory on the processor itself so the closer you are to kind of the main bits of the processor that are executing your code the smaller you are because there's a lot of things that need to be connected on the physical processor and there just isn't a lot of space so then you have to go through extra sets of interfaces and out to kind of other parts of the chip to get to bigger levels of cache and so the processor always wants to look in the closest cache because that cache is fastest if it's not
保持工作集是描述它的一种方式，即你正在操作的数据量，如果你需要进行大量操作，在移动到下一组数据之前对一小部分数据进行操作，会比如果你这样做更快，所以如果你认为我有一系列我需要在图像上执行的操作，比如首先我想，你知道，对所有像素进行高斯模糊，然后我想做一个边缘检测，然后我想做一个，你堆叠了五件事，嗯，如果它们现在假设不相互依赖，如果你把一个像素通过所有这些步骤，在某些方面会比执行所有像素通过第一步，然后所有像素通过第二步，然后所有像素通过第一步，然后所有像素通过
there you have what's called a cache miss and then you got to go out to the next cache miss go out to the next cache miss go out to main memory if it's not in main memory it has to go out to the next. Cache, MISC, go out to the next. Cache, MISC, go out to main memory. If it's not in main memory, it has to go all the way out to hard disk, which is terrible. It means it's going to take forever in processor. Yeah, I think each way it's like an order of magnitude, right? Or orders of magnitude, yeah. Oh, wow. So it's really bad, right? And so when we talk about optimizing, there's a lot of things you can do once you kind of understand that that's how the processor works.
第二步，然后所有像素通过第三步更快。因为你的图像大小会非常非常大。如果你从第一个像素开始，遍历每一个像素，当你到达最后一个像素时，第一个像素就不在内存中了，或者它不在最近的缓存中了，所以对吧，大量的内存访问优化都是围绕这一点构建的，所以如果你看看矩阵乘法是如何完成的，如果你处理非常大的矩阵，他们教你手工乘法矩阵的幼稚方法在计算机设置中效果并不好，主要是因为内存访问模式的工作方式，内存是聚集在一起的，你以便宜的价格获得附近的位置，然后你在
To keep the working set is one way to describe it the amount of data that you're operating on if you need to do lots of operations doing it on a small set of data before moving to the next set of data is going to be faster than if you so if you think about like i have a sequence of operations i need to do on a on an image like first i want to you know gaussian blur all the pixels then i want to do an edge detector then i want to do and you kind of stack up like five things uh and if they were not dependent on each other hypothetically for now if you took a single pixel through all of those steps that is in some ways going to be faster than doing uh all of the pixels through the first step then all of the pixels through the second step then all of the pixels through the first step, then all of the pixels
一个较小的工作集中操作，所以更快的矩阵乘法操作利用了这一点，是的，这很有道理，是的，所有这些东西，我的意思是如果你正在做，希望是，你知道，1% 的代码占用了 99% 的 CPU 使用率。所以，你知道，你不必超级优化一切。但是，你知道，像，例如，你说的图像处理，在底层操作图像的部分，必须非常快。这是对的。所以你指出了几件事。
through the second step, then all of the pixels through the third step. Because the size of your image is going to be really, really big. And if you start at the first pixel and you go through every single pixel, by the time you get to the last pixel, the first pixel isn't in memory anymore, or it's not in the closest cache anymore and so right a lot of optimization for memory access is built around that and so if you look at kind of how a matrix multiply is done if you get to really big matrices the naive way they kind of teach you to multiply matrices by hand doesn't work that well in a computer setting mostly because of how memory access patterns work memory comes that is clumped together you kind of get close by locations for cheap and then you operate in
首先，是确保你确定了值得花时间优化的代码。是的，我们应该为之前做个推销。我们有一集关于分析的节目，你知道，找出你代码中哪些部分是最快的。如果你还没有看过，你一定要去看看。所以这是你总是应该做的第一件伟大的事情。
a smaller working set and so bastar matrix multiply operations take advantage of that yeah that makes sense yeah a lot of this stuff i mean if you're doing, the hope is that, you know, 1% of your code is 99% of the CPU usage. And so, you know, you don't have to super optimize everything. But, you know, something like, for example, you said image processing, the part that manipulates the images at a low level, like has to be extremely fast. That's right. And so there's a couple of things you point out there.
因为一旦你开始进入我谈到的这些优化技术，你的代码确实变得更难阅读，通常是因为它在做一些稍微不明显的事情，所以除非必须，否则你不想先去那里。第二件事是使用其他人编写的工具，我想上一集或两集前你谈到了线性代数库，是的，对吧，所以使用线性代数库，如果你要进行矩阵乘法，你希望得到的是别人花了很多时间找出乘两个大矩阵的绝对最快方法，因为如果你幼稚地做，你可能不会像他们那么快。是的，这会有巨大的不同。
First of all, is making sure you identify the code that it's worth spending this time to optimize. Yeah, we should do a pitch for earlier. We had an episode on profiling, you know, finding out what parts of your code are the fastest. And you should definitely check that out if you haven't already. So that's a great first thing you should always do.
所以识别常见的代码块并尝试找到拥有这些代码良好实现的其他人的代码。是的，完全正确。所以假设现在你有很多数据，它不适合内存，或者访问速度超级慢，你知道你不能，这不是一个关于你知道加速你知道展开循环或类似事情的问题，现实是你只是有大量数据，你需要从大海捞针中取出针，所以这被称为你知道索引或反向索引，所以你知道例如数据库，如果你使用 SQLite 或使用 MySQL 或这些数据库之一，你可以存储你知道十亿条条目，然后你说你
Because once you start getting into these optimization optimization techniques that i've talked about your code does become harder to read often uh because it's doing something slightly non-obvious and uh so you don't want to go there first unless you have to the second thing is using tools other people have written so you were talking about linear algebra libraries i think last episode or two episodes ago yeah right and so using a linear algebra library if you're going to do matrix multiply what you're hopefully getting is someone else who spent a ton of time figuring out the absolute fastest way to multiply two large matrices because if you do it naively you're probably not going to be as fast as them. Yeah, it'll make a huge difference.
知道我需要你知道 Patrick Wheeler，它会立即给你，对吧？但你知道，如果你写了一个 for 循环，它会永远运行，所以他们在做什么？在幕后，任何以亚线性时间返回结果的东西，这意味着比你写一个 for 循环并将所有内容放在内存中更快，它正在使用两件事之一。无论你使用什么数据库，它总是归结为两件事之一。那就是树或哈希。所以这意味着树只是意味着你根据某些标准划分数据，并且标准的设置方式是，如果你在标准的某一边，那么你知道你的答案不在另一边。例如，你可以只根据某人名字的字母制作一棵树。所以树可以说，某人名字的第一个字母是
And so identifying blocks of code that are common and trying to find other people who have good implementations of those. Yeah, totally. So let's say now you have a lot of data and it's not fitting in memory or it's just super slow to access and you know you can't it's not a matter of you know speeding up the the you know unrolling loops or things like that the reality is like you just have a ton of data and you need to pull out like a needle in a haystack so this is called you know an index or a reverse index so you know for example a database if you use sqlite or use my sql or one of these databases and you can store you know a billion entries and then you say you
小于或等于 M 吗？如果是，你走一个方向。如果不是，你走另一个方向。所以在这个例子中，如果我在寻找，你知道，Patrick，我说，好的，第一个字母是 P。所以我知道树左边的任何东西都不可能是 Patrick。所以我只关注树的右边。这只是假设一棵二叉树。所以通过这种方式，你实际上可以搜索，你已经有效地搜索了所有条目，但你只是，通过做一个决定，你已经消除了半数条目。你只是知道，你知道，通过做一个决定，你已经消除了半数条目。你只是知道它不是那些中的任何一个。所以有 B 树，
know i need you know patrick wheeler and it just gives it to you instantly right but you know if you wrote a for loop it would take forever so what are they doing? Under the hood, anything that returns results in sublinear time, which means faster than if you wrote a for loop and had everything in memory, it's using one of two things. No matter what database you use, it's always boiling down one of two things. And that's either a tree or a hash. So what that means is a tree just means you're dividing the data based on some criteria and the criteria is set up in a way where if you're on sort of one side of the criteria, then you know your answer isn't on the other side. So for example, you could make a tree just based on the letters of someone's name. So the tree could say, is the first letter of someone's name
有二叉树。那些是不同的。有红，有红黑树。是的。有很多不同的树。有 R 树，R 星树。有视点树。有大量的不同树。它们都被设计为尽可能快地消除选项，这意味着与其搜索一百万个条目，你正在搜索五个，对吧？五个加上再做六个决定。所以你已经从你必须做的一百万件事变成了 11 件。所以这就是当涉及到这些类型的搜索时一切工作的方式。
less than or equal to M? And if it is, you go one direction. If it's not, you go a different direction. So in this case, if I'm looking for, you know, Patrick, I say, okay, the first letter is a P. So I know that anything that's on the left side of the tree can't be Patrick. So I just focus on the right side of the tree. And this is just assuming a binary tree. And so in this way, you can actually search, you've effectively searched all of the entries, but you've just, by making one decision, you've eliminated half of the entries. You just know that, you know, by making one decision, you've eliminated half of the entries. You just know that it's not any of those. And so there's B trees,
就像如果你在谷歌地图上输入一个地址，你会立即得到它。这是因为下面有某种树。另一种方法是哈希，这实际上只是某种形式的聚类。例如，我可能会说，好的，让我们把所有名字以 P 开头的人都拿出来，把他们放在一个文件里或内存中的一个点上。每个人名字以 J 开头，我放在内存中的不同点。所以我得到你知道有人在搜索 Patrick
there's binary trees. Those are different. There's red, there's red, black trees. Yeah. There's a bunch of different trees. There's R trees, R star trees. There's vantage point trees. There's a ton of different trees. And they're all designed to eliminate options as quickly as possible, which should mean instead of searching a million entries, you're searching five, right? Five plus making another six decisions. So you've gone from a million things you have to do to 11. And so this is how everything works when it comes to these kinds of searches.
我知道去查看 P 文件，如果有人在搜索 Jason，我查看 J 文件，所以它不是一棵树，它实际上只是这些桶，但它确实做了同样的事情，所以嗯，你知道，同样有十亿种不同的方法来进行哈希和聚类，嗯，实际上有一些非常有趣的工作，比如神经网络和嵌入和聚类。这就像相对，你知道，最近，而且就像他们一直在发明新的方法来做这件事。但归根结底，它归结为那两件事之一。所以如果你曾经，你知道，尝试制作你自己的 Minecraft 或做过任何类似的事情，当你意识到，我怎么把所有这些都存储在内存中？这不可能。
Like if you're on Google Maps and you put in an address, you get it back right away. It's because there's some kind of tree underneath. Another way to do it is hashing, which is really just kind of a form of clustering. So for example, I might say, okay, let's take everyone whose name starts with a P and let's put them in one file or in one spot in memory. And everyone whose name starts with a J, I put in a different spot of memory. And so i get you know someone's searching for patrick
他们是怎么做到的？好吧，他们几乎肯定是在使用树或哈希。是的，我认为在优化的背景下，你应该问自己的是，如果你的代码运行缓慢是因为你试图在大量数据中找到某样东西，你能应用树或使用哈希来消除
i know to look at the p file and if someone's searching for jason i look at the j file so it's not a tree it's really just these buckets but it does kind of the same thing and so um you know there's again there's a billion different ways to do hashing and clustering um there's actually some really interesting work with like neural networks and embeddings and clusterings. It's like relatively, you know, recent and like, it's like they're inventing new ways to do this all the time. But at the end of the day, it breaks down to one of those two things. So if you've ever, you know, tried to make your own Minecraft or done anything like that, where you realize like, how am I storing all this in memory? It's impossible.
你需要搜索的大部分数据更快，是的，完全正确，嗯，而且这涉及到然后做你知道某种延迟计算之类的事情，就像在 Minecraft 的情况下，如果你没有看某样东西，那么他们可以不处理那些块，直到有人看着它。所以有一大堆所谓的航位推算类型的过程在进行。好吧，对于其他流行语，你有像二叉空间分割
And how did they do it? Well, they're almost certainly using either a tree or a hash. Yeah, and I think in the context of optimization, what you should be asking yourself is, if your code is running slow because you're trying to find something in a whole bunch of data, can you apply a tree or use hashing to eliminate
或类似的东西，它们也是一种树，你把世界分成几部分，这样你就可以说如果有人向前看，我怎么消除他们身后的一切，因为我知道他们现在不可能在看它，对吧，是的，完全正确，是的，二叉空间分割字面上是一棵二叉树，其中每个决定都是一个超平面，所以如果你有一个特定的区域，你说那个区域是否穿过超平面，如果是，那么我必须看两个方向，但如果它
the bulk of the data you need to search through more quickly yeah exactly um and and that gets into then doing you know kind of deferred computation and things like that like in the case of minecraft um if you're not looking at something, then they can not process those chunks until someone's looking at it. And so there's a whole bunch of sort of dead reckoning type processes that go on. Well, for other buzzwords, you have like binary space partitioning
不穿过超平面，如果你正在看的区域，比如你的视锥体，只在超平面的一边，那么你可以跳过另一边的一切，所以是的，有索引。另一件事是，你知道，超越只在一台机器上运行，有分布式计算，实际上有一些单机分布式计算，比如多线程、多处理、线程池之类的事情。所以例如，假设你有一个巨大的项目列表，你想……一个巨大的字符串列表，你想把它们全部大写。我的意思是这是一个非常琐碎的例子，但你可以写一个 for 循环，从 1 到 20 亿，你知道，s 等于 s 点大写，对吧？但这太慢了。你也可以说，让我，你知道，
or things like that, which are also kind of a form of tree where you're dividing up a world into parts so that you can say if someone's looking forward how do i eliminate everything that's behind them because i know they can't be looking at it right now yep yeah exactly yeah binary space partitioning is literally a binary tree um where every decision is a hyperplane and so if you have a certain area you say does that area cross the hyperplane if it does then I have to look at both directions but if it
把我的数据分成两批，你知道，从 0 到 5 亿，从 5 亿到 10 亿，并让两个线程处理它们。这还可以，但它有另一个问题，如果因为某种疯狂的原因，前 5 亿个字符串非常小，而后 5 亿个非常大，那么第一个线程会完成得快得多，你将永远等待第二个线程。所以你可能会说，好的，我要为每个条目创建一个单独的线程。我要创建十亿个线程。然后你运行该命令，你必须重启你的电脑，因为它着火了，对吧？所以线程池是处理这种情况的一种方法。
doesn't cross the hyperplane if the area you're looking at like your frustrum is only on one side of the hyperplane then you can skip everything on the other side so yeah there's indexing. Another thing is, you know, going beyond just running on one machine, there's distributed computing, which actually there is some one machine distributed computing, like multi-threading, multi-processing, thread pools, things like that. So for example, let's say you have a huge list of items and you want to... a huge list of strings and you want to capitalize all of them. I mean this is very kind of a trivial example, but you could write a for loop and go from 1 to 2 billion, you know, s equals s dot uppercase, right? But that's pretty slow. You could also say, let me, you know,
所以你可以给一个线程池，你知道，十亿件事来计算。它会，你知道，找出最佳线程数，取决于它有多复杂，但一些线程池会找出最佳线程数。就像如果你有 16 个核心和超线程，它们会说，好的，你有 32 个实际线程，它会将所有 32 个线程分配给 32 个字符串，当它们完成时，它会分配更多更多更多。
take my data and divide it into two batches, you know, from zero to half a billion, and from half a billion to a billion, and have two threads working on them. That's okay, but that has another issue, which is if for some crazy reason the first 500 million strings are very tiny and the next 500 million are huge, then the first thread will finish much quicker and you'll just be waiting on the second thread forever. So you might say, okay, I'm going to make a separate thread for every entry. I'm going to make a billion threads. And you run that command and you have to restart your computer because it's just caught on fire, right? So thread pools are a way to handle that.
把我的数据分成两批，你知道，从零到五亿，再从五亿到十亿，然后让两个线程分别处理它们。这没问题，但它有另一个问题，就是如果因为某些疯狂的原因，前五亿个字符串非常小，而后五亿个非常大，那么第一个线程会快得多完成，而你只能永远等待第二个线程。所以你可能会说，好吧，我要为每个条目创建一个单独的线程。我要创建十亿个线程。然后你运行那个命令，你就得重启电脑，因为它直接烧毁了，对吧？所以线程池就是处理这种情况的方法。
So you can give a thread pool, you know, a billion things to compute. And it will, you know, figure out the optimal number of threads, depending on how sophisticated it is, but some thread pools will figure out the optimal number of threads. Like if you have 16 cores and hyper-threading, they'll say, okay, you have 32 actual threads, and it'll assign all 32 threads to 32 strings, and as they finish, it will assign more and more and more.
所以你可以给线程池，你知道，十亿个任务去计算。它会，你知道，找出最佳的线程数量，取决于它的复杂程度，但有些线程池会计算出最佳的线程数。比如如果你有 16 个核心和超线程，它会说，好吧，你有 32 个实际线程，它会将所有 32 个线程分配给 32 个字符串，随着它们完成，它会分配越来越多的任务。
So at any given time, you have 32 of these being processed, and you have a queue that could be huge. Now, eventually, when the queue is exhausted, it'll tell you we're all done. So that's a clear way to get some good benefit. I mean, there's obviously more complexity there, so you should only do it when you're working on code that takes a long time to execute. Another part beyond threading, kind of taking it to the next level, would be networking. So with threading, you're still limited by what your one computer can do.
所以在任何给定时间，你都有 32 个这样的任务在处理，而且你可能有一个巨大的队列。最终，当队列耗尽时，它会告诉你我们完成了。所以这是一种获得良好收益的明确方法。我的意思是，这里显然有更多的复杂性，所以你应该只在处理需要很长时间执行的代码时才这样做。除了线程之外的另一个部分，将其提升到一个新的水平，就是网络。所以使用线程，你仍然受到单台计算机能力的限制。
But you might say, oh, I want to use 1 you know, a thousand computers. I want them all to be serving some website. And so once you get into networking, then you get more into, you know, like load balancing, which is, you know, similar to the way Threadpool works. It's just kind of taking it to the networking level. And it requires a little bit more statistics because there's more uncertainty. But, you know, load balancing is effectively saying, okay, I have 100 machines. Let me make sure all the machines are equally loaded. So if one machine is serving one request, but that request is really expensive for some reason, then they'll give all the feature requests among the other machines.
但你可能会说，哦，我想用一千台计算机。我希望它们都能为某个网站提供服务。一旦你进入网络领域，你就会更多地接触到负载均衡，这与线程池的工作方式类似。它只是将其提升到了网络层面。它需要更多的统计数据，因为有更多的不确定性。但是，负载均衡实际上是在说，好吧，我有 100 台机器。让我确保所有机器的负载相等。因此，如果一台机器正在处理一个请求，但由于某种原因该请求非常昂贵，那么它会将所有功能请求分发给其他机器。
And load bouncing is similar to thread pools, except you're constantly having to sort of pull all the machines and find out if they're healthy or not. There's also other kind of networking tricks for optimization. There's reliable UDP, which means typically when you do things over the Internet, you do things over the internet you do tcp and that means uh the tcp protocol guarantees that i get every packet and i get it in order so if i want to send patrick you know uh email i want him to get every letter in that email and i want him to get them in order like i don't want him to get this weird jumble of letters. And so TCP seems
负载均衡与线程池类似，只是你必须不断地轮询所有机器，找出它们是否健康。还有其他类型的网络优化技巧。有可靠的 UDP，这意味着通常当你通过互联网做事情时，你会使用 TCP，这意味着 TCP 协议保证我能收到每个数据包，并且按顺序收到。所以如果我想给 Patrick 发电子邮件，我希望他收到那封邮件里的每一个字母，并且按顺序收到，我不希望他收到一堆乱七八糟的字母。所以 TCP 看起来
very reasonable for that. But you may not need the in order part. There's often times where you're just sending a bunch of data to someone. And let's say I'm sending a file to Patrick. He doesn't need to get all of the bytes in order. He just needs to get all the bytes and put them in the right place as he gets them. And so that's an example where I could use reliable UDP and other kind of protocols to get a huge speed up. So I think about networking and the question is going to be when you have computers put together and you start to have an issue and you start looking at what. And when you get to networking level, you really have to be careful about collecting a lot of really good statistics so that you know there is a problem. Because often problems go undetected for a long time.
对此非常合理。但你可能不需要按顺序的部分。很多时候你只是给某人发送一堆数据。假设我正在给 Patrick 发送一个文件。他不需要按顺序接收所有字节。他只需要接收所有字节，并在收到它们时将它们放在正确的位置。这就是我可以使用可靠 UDP 和其他协议来获得巨大速度提升的一个例子。所以我考虑网络，问题在于当你把计算机放在一起，开始出现问题并开始查看原因时。当你达到网络层面时，你真的必须小心收集大量非常好的统计数据，以便你知道存在问题。因为问题往往会在很长一段时间内未被发现。
I'm pretty tongue tied tonight. And so for networking, one of the things like Jason was was saying you have a request comes in and it takes a long time and you need to load balance so what you would be looking for is what parameters should i be watching to see if i need to add a load balancer or change the algorithm i load balancers using or add new computers and so you would want to for instance look at what do the longest one percent of queries take or 99 of queries take longer than this or that? Or, you know, basically, what is the histogram of response times? And you said some, oops, sorry, go ahead.
我今晚说话有点结巴。对于网络，就像 Jason 所说的，有一个请求进来，它需要很长时间，你需要负载均衡，所以你要寻找的是我应该观察哪些参数来看看我是否需要添加负载均衡器，或者改变负载均衡器使用的算法，或者添加新计算机。所以你会想要，例如，查看最慢的 1% 的查询需要多长时间，或者 99% 的查询是否比这个或那个时间长？或者，基本上，响应时间的直方图是什么？你说了一些，哎呀，抱歉，你继续。
Oh, I should say, if you ever hear the term P50 and P99, it's what Patrick's referring to. So P50 is what is the mean latency for something and P99 is, you know, 99% of your requests have a latency less than that number. Right. So, so you might have, when someone specifies how good a response time they want, they kind of often mean two things or three things they want, you know, 99% of requests should complete within 10 milliseconds, but 100% of requests or nearly 100% should complete within one second. So I know that occasionally something will happen and I can't complete within 100 milliseconds, 10 milliseconds, whatever I said, but I never want a request to take too, too long.
哦，我应该说，如果你听到 P50 和 P99 这个术语，这就是 Patrick 所指的。P50 是某件事的平均延迟，P99 是 99% 的请求延迟小于该数字。对吧。所以，当有人指定他们想要的响应时间有多好时，他们通常指的是两三件事，他们希望 99% 的请求在 10 毫秒内完成，但 100% 的请求或接近 100% 的请求应该在一秒内完成。所以我知道偶尔会发生一些事情，我无法在 100 毫秒、10 毫秒或我说的任何时间内完成，但我从不希望请求花费太长时间。
And so then that helps define how you would do load balancing, what architecture for your network you need. What do you do if, you know, 500 milliseconds has gone by? Should you like abort the request and start it again in your remaining five? Like, how do you deliver on that? You know, what you're trying to guarantee? Yeah, and it gets really interesting once networking is involved there was a case in a place i worked where it actually made sense to send the load balancer to requests every time so in other words like like imagine that like you need a you need some data and you literally ask the same system for the same piece of data twice immediately one one after another, and then you pick the one that returns first. And the idea is, you know, you have so many resources, but you can't
这有助于定义你将如何进行负载均衡，以及你需要什么样的网络架构。如果 500 毫秒过去了，你该怎么办？你应该中止请求并在剩下的五秒内重新开始吗？你如何实现这一点？你试图保证什么？是的，一旦涉及网络，事情就变得非常有趣。我工作过的一个地方有一个案例，实际上有意义的是每次都向负载均衡器发送请求，换句话说，想象一下你需要一些数据，你实际上连续两次向同一个系统请求同一条数据，然后你选择先返回的那个。这个想法是，你有这么多资源，但你无法
control the latency. And so the only way you can do it is by making multiple calls at exactly the same time with exactly the same data and just picking the one that returns first. But this is an interesting optimization before you were talking about hashing. And so I guess when you go to distribute a computer, the same optimization technique kind of becomes called partitioning, where you say some requests for certain usernames go to this computer, other usernames go to this other computer, right? And you've partitioned the request, but you can, if your partitioning scheme is complex
控制延迟。所以你唯一能做的方法就是同时用完全相同的数据进行多次调用，然后只选择先返回的那个。但在你谈论哈希之前，这是一个有趣的优化。所以我想当你去分发一台计算机时，同样的优化技术被称为分区，你说某些用户名的请求去这台计算机，其他用户名去另一台计算机，对吧？你已经对请求进行了分区，但是，如果你的分区方案很复杂
or for various reasons, you may want the load balancer or the thing sitting out in front to issue requests to some or all of the computers behind it. And the first one who has an answer replies back. And then if the others don't ever end up or don't have the data necessary to respond, they just never respond.
或者由于各种原因，你可能希望负载均衡器或位于前面的东西向其后面的部分或所有计算机发出请求。第一个有答案的会回复。如果其他人最终没有或没有必要的数据来响应，他们就永远不会响应。
Yeah, I mean, you can do all sorts of interesting things. I mean, the machine behind the load balancer could know that it's taking too long and give up on the assumption that the load balancer will pick someone else. And yeah, it gets pretty kind of math heavy, which again is a good reason to use off-the-shelf components for this. Don't try and write your own load balancer. But I think it's also a really good reason to,
是的，我的意思是，你可以做各种有趣的事情。我的意思是，负载均衡器后面的机器可能知道它花费的时间太长了，并放弃了负载均衡器会选择其他人的假设。是的，这变得非常依赖数学，这也是使用现成组件的一个很好的理由。不要尝试编写自己的负载均衡器。但我认为这也是一个很好的理由，
when you start designing a system, understand what your goals are and also to try to make sure to collect really good data so that you can analyze problems when they come up yeah definitely i mean we've talked about this in the past but we can't stress enough how important it is to collect just a ton of data um you don't want to be in a position where you have some problem and you have to start collecting data to fix it. That's bad news. The last piece of this, the top of the stack are just algorithmic improvements. So if you haven't heard of this,
当你开始设计系统时，了解你的目标是什么，并尽量确保收集非常好的数据，以便在问题出现时进行分析。是的，绝对的，我的意思是我们在过去谈论过这个问题，但我们怎么强调收集大量数据的重要性都不为过。你不想处于那种有问题并且必须开始收集数据来修复它的境地。那是坏消息。这部分的最后一块，堆栈的顶部只是算法改进。所以如果你没听说过这个，
there's this thing called big O notation. It's just a fancy way of saying this is sort of the way that a particular algorithm grows in terms of computational you know computational time so in other words if something is n squared then that means as the number of elements increases the time it takes to get the answer you want goes up exponentially. If something's order n, then that means it scales linearly. So, for example, if you want to loop through a list of strings and count the number of letters in the string, in each string, and you assume that the strings are pretty small you might say that oh you know the length of the string doesn't really matter this is order n in terms of the number of
有一个东西叫大 O 符号。这只是一种花哨的说法，即特定算法在计算时间方面的增长方式，换句话说，如果某事是 n 平方，这意味着随着元素数量的增加，得到你想要的答案所需的时间呈指数级增长。如果某事是 O(n)，这意味着它呈线性扩展。例如，如果你想循环遍历一个字符串列表并计算每个字符串中的字母数量，并且你假设字符串很小，你可能会说字符串的长度并不重要，这是关于数量的 O(n)
strings as I add more strings that I have to count the letters of you know I increase linearly if you're using as you said before like trees and hashing and things like that you can actually do sublinear computations. So if you want to find, for example, if you want to find the 10 real estate agents closest to you and you've put all of your real estate agents into an R tree or an R star tree. Now, putting them into the R star tree, that might take N squared, and that might take two days or something, right? Or N log N, I think, is what it takes.
字符串，当我添加更多需要计算字母的字符串时，我呈线性增加。如果你像之前说的那样使用树和哈希等，你实际上可以进行亚线性计算。所以如果你想找到，例如，如果你想找到离你最近的 10 个房地产经纪人，并且你已经把你所有的房地产经纪人放入了 R 树或 R 星树中。现在，把它们放入 R 星树，那可能需要 N 平方，那可能需要两天左右，对吧？或者我认为是 N log N。
But that might take a long time. But once you have that R star tree built, then you can look up the K nearest neighbors. You can look up the nearest realtors in sublinear time. So even though there's 100 realtors, you only have to look at two to know that those two are the closest. And so, you know, whenever you start dealing with big values for N, you know, when you're looking at, a billion websites or a million strings or what have you, that's where this big O notation becomes really important because it will tell you kind of the best case and the worst case.
但这可能需要很长时间。但一旦你建立了那个 R 星树，你就可以查找 K 个最近的邻居。你可以在亚线性时间内查找最近的房地产经纪人。所以即使有 100 个房地产经纪人，你也只需要看两个就知道那两个是最近的。所以，每当你开始处理 N 的大值时，当你看着十亿个网站或一百万个字符串等等时，这就是大 O 符号变得非常重要的地方，因为它会告诉你最好情况和最坏情况。
I think big O is the worst case. There's also little o, and then there's like sigma o. Little o is the best case, and sigma o is the amortized cost. So, for example, let's say you're building this tree and most of the time it takes log logarithmic time but every 10 000 times you have to do some big rebalancing that's expensive that's where you would say it's sigma o log N, because you might have to pay a big hit and you should kind of design your system around that, but it's rare. So yeah, all of these different notations
我认为大 O 是最坏的情况。还有小 o，还有 sigma o。小 o 是最好的情况，sigma o 是摊销成本。例如，假设你正在构建这棵树，大多数时候它需要对数时间，但每 10,000 次你必须做一些昂贵的大规模重新平衡，这就是你会说它是 sigma o log N 的地方，因为你可能必须付出巨大的代价，你应该围绕它设计你的系统，但这很少见。所以是的，所有这些不同的符号
and algorithmic improvements, that's sort of a last ditch effort. Like if you have gone through all of these things and you realize you actually need a brand new algorithm and need to do some research, then that's another opportunity. through all of these things and you you realize you actually need a brand new algorithm um and need to do some research then uh that's that's uh that's another opportunity sort of i mean i don't want to be particularly contradictory and what you said at the end if you need to invent some new algorithm yes probably last ditch effort but i think actually reducing algorithmic complexity
和算法改进，那算是最后的手段。如果你已经经历了所有这些事情，并且意识到你实际上需要一个全新的算法并需要做一些研究，那么这是另一个机会。经历了所有这些事情，你意识到你实际上需要一个全新的算法，并且需要做一些研究，那么这是另一个机会。我的意思是，我不想特别矛盾，在你最后说的话里，如果你需要发明一些新算法，是的，可能是最后的手段，但我认为实际上减少算法复杂度
is often your first step you should approach, which is... Oh, that's true. If I'm storing all of my... If I'm searching for something and I'm just storing it in an array and binary search doesn't work because my array is not sorted, then you should say, oh, maybe I should sort my array and use binary search. Or maybe I should use a tree. Or maybe a hash map would be appropriate here.
通常是你应该采取的第一步，也就是……哦，那是真的。如果我正在存储我所有的……如果我正在搜索某样东西，并且我只是把它存储在一个数组中，而二分搜索不起作用，因为我的数组没有排序，那么你应该说，哦，也许我应该对我的数组进行排序并使用二分搜索。或者也许我应该使用树。或者也许哈希映射在这里是合适的。
And the reason why I think that is kind of the first thing you should go to is because that code is still going to be pretty readable, and often pretty readable. And you'll end up not wasting your time trying to tweak your compiler only to find out that you need to switch to a different architecture, and you lose all your gains. Those are going to be the most portable changes and can often lead to code that outstrips any other optimization you might be able to do. Yeah, that's actually a really good point. So like a couple of things. One thing is definitely use off the shelf algorithms., don't really ever write your own sort or anything like that. But you're right.
我认为这是你应该首先考虑的原因是，因为代码仍然会非常可读，而且通常非常可读。你最终不会浪费时间试图调整你的编译器，结果却发现你需要切换到不同的架构，并且你失去了所有的收益。这些将是最可移植的更改，并且通常可以导致代码超过你可能能够做的任何其他优化。是的，这确实是一个很好的观点。所以有几件事。一件事绝对是使用现成的算法，不要真的写你自己的排序之类的东西。但你是对的。
I mean, if you have sort of 10 elements, you might just use, you know, for loop and sort them really quickly, you know, quickly in terms of effort. But then all of a sudden your requirements change and I have 1,000 elements or 10 or a million elements. And then you're right. I mean, you could tweak the compiler all day long, but if your sort is, you know, the bubble sort that you wrote when you first started the project, then nothing is going to help you other than improving your algorithm. And I think one of the things about optimization that's difficult is the,
我的意思是，如果你有 10 个元素，你可能只是使用 for 循环并快速对它们进行排序，在努力方面很快。但突然间你的需求变了，我有 1,000 个元素或 100 万个元素。然后你是对的。我的意思是，你可以整天调整编译器，但如果你的排序是你刚开始项目时写的冒泡排序，那么除了改进你的算法之外，什么都帮不了你。我认为关于优化的困难之处在于，
oh, I don't ever know how comfortable i am feeling about uh referring to something as the art of but the art of optimization is knowing when not to optimize or how much to optimize and it's something that's you can't often write down you just kind of have to use judgment but for instance it may be that you have implemented merge sort because quick sort a good implementation of quick sort isn't available on your system or whatever and you're debating whether or not you should use it you really should look at your use cases and say hey it turns out i'm normally only sorting 100 items though maybe it isn't i don't know what the breakdown is but often merge short actually at the end does, or quick sort at the end does merge sort because it performs slightly better on small data sets.
哦，我不知道我对将某事称为艺术有多舒服，但优化的艺术是知道何时不优化或优化多少，这是你通常无法写下来的东西，你只需要运用判断力，但例如，你可能已经实现了归并排序，因为你的系统上没有好的快速排序实现，或者其他什么，你正在争论是否应该使用它，你真的应该看看你的用例并说，嘿，事实证明我通常只对 100 个项目进行排序，虽然也许不是，我不知道细分是什么，但通常归并排序实际上在最后，或者快速排序在最后确实是归并排序，因为它在小数据集上表现稍好。
And so there's like some crossover point, right? this very exotic binary tree, because I think my binary tree might, you know, may not be exactly the best thing, is knowing when to invest that complexity and adding, you know, that to your code and potentially causing unintended consequences by having more complicated code than you did before, even if it does end up faster in some cases. Yep. One last thing about algorithm improvements.
所以有一个交叉点，对吧？这个非常奇特的二叉树，因为我认为我的二叉树可能不是最好的东西，是知道何时投入这种复杂性并将其添加到你的代码中，并可能通过拥有比以前更复杂的代码而导致意想不到的后果，即使它在某些情况下确实更快。是的。关于算法改进的最后一件事。
A lot of what you'll do here isn't going to be inventing a new algorithm, maybe unless you're a professor or something, but it's actually going to be finding the right approximation. Like for example, if you have a list of numbers and they're streaming in,
你在这里做的很多事情不会是发明一种新算法，除非你是一位教授什么的，但实际上是找到正确的近似值。例如，如果你有一个数字列表，它们正在流式传输，
maybe it's, you know, you're building your own load balancer and you have a list of latencies that are coming through, you could store all of them and now you can find the average latency and it's the P99 latency and P50, all of that, as we talked about. But that's a lot of numbers. I mean, you're getting maybe 100 of these a second. You don't want to keep this enormous list of latencies, right?
也许是你正在构建自己的负载均衡器，并且有一系列延迟正在通过，你可以存储所有这些，现在你可以找到平均延迟，它是 P99 延迟和 P50，所有这些，正如我们所讨论的。但这有很多数字。我的意思是，你每秒可能得到 100 个这样的数字。你不想保留这个巨大的延迟列表，对吧？
So what you can do is is approximate you could you know maybe store the first 10 000 and then store some hyper parameters about you know all the ones you've seen up until now or you could keep some kind of like distribution estimator common filter or something like that where you're not storing you're only storing two numbers, but you're just keeping those two numbers updated in some recursive way. And so especially as your application grows in size and popularity and what have you, a big part of it is figuring out where you can make approximations and what the trade-offs are.
所以你可以做的是近似，你可以存储前 10,000 个，然后存储一些关于你到目前为止看到的所有内容的超参数，或者你可以保留某种分布估计器卡尔曼滤波器之类的东西，你不需要存储所有内容，你只需要存储两个数字，但你只是以某种递归方式更新这两个数字。因此，特别是随着你的应用程序在规模和受欢迎程度上的增长，很大一部分是弄清楚你在哪里可以进行近似以及权衡是什么。
Well, I think that's a wrap. Yeah. So I promise I will get t-shirts, or I will at least have sent myself a t-shirt that I'm happy with. I'm going to do that before I subject anyone to buying a t-shirt that may not actually look good when you get it. But I promise I will have a t-shirt prototype by next show. And I think we're actually going to have an interview next show.
好吧，我想这就是总结。是的。所以我保证我会买 T 恤，或者我至少会给自己寄一件我满意的 T 恤。我会在让任何人购买一件当你收到时可能看起来并不好看的 T 恤之前这样做。但我保证我会在下一次节目之前有一个 T 恤原型。而且我认为我们下一次节目实际上会有一个采访。
It's not a guarantee, but it seems to be coming around that way. It's actually going to be really cool. I'm excited about this guest that we're going to have on the show. And yeah, if you have any questions, if you've had any like wicked, you know, optimization stories where like you fit, you know, the whole world in a cheerio or something, that'd be awesome. Post on Facebook, post on reply to us on Twitter. And yeah, have fun, you guys. Yeah, we need we get a fair amount of user feedback and email.
这不是保证，但看起来是这样。这实际上会非常酷。我对我们将要参加节目的这位嘉宾感到兴奋。是的，如果你有任何问题，如果你有任何像邪恶的优化故事，比如你把整个世界装进一个麦片圈里什么的，那太棒了。发布在 Facebook 上，在 Twitter 上回复我们。是的，玩得开心，伙计们。是的，我们需要，我们得到了相当多的用户反馈和电子邮件。
So thank you guys and gals for doing that. We should have more featured like emails that get written to us we've had a lot of really good ones yeah maybe we'll do another mailbag or something or even just like people yeah like write like we should give something for people to write in about and then we should like read the best ones like in this case tell us your best
所以谢谢你们这样做。我们应该有更多像写给我们的电子邮件那样的专题，我们有很多非常好的。是的，也许我们会做另一个邮件袋之类的，或者甚至只是像人们写的那样，我们应该给人们一些写信的内容，然后我们应该像读最好的那些一样，在这种情况下，告诉我们你最好的
optimization story and then like we'll read it next time yeah that's true that's true if anyone has a cool optimization story we'll definitely we'll bring it up as our intro next time all right well thank y'all cool see you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
优化故事，然后我们下次会读它。是的，那是真的，那是真的，如果有人有很酷的优化故事，我们一定会把它作为我们下次的开场白。好吧，谢谢你们。酷，回头见。开场音乐是 Biner Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品以重新混合、改编作品，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。